[Musique]
monsieur d'un bonjour
bonjour se bat aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne atari qui s'appelle thinkers où
nous sommes en direct vous reçoit dans
le cadre de votre activité d'économistes
vous êtes tous les trois économistes
est-ce que vous pouvez bien vous
présentez un par un on va commencer par
via rail alors je sais mireille brière
je suis économiste à l'université de
toulouse jean jaurès
et donc économistes atterrés et je
n'occupe plus particulièrement des
questions d'économie travail l'économie
sociale et solidaire de la question des
coopératives par exemple eric donc eric
baer je suis économiste à l'université
de bordeaux donc membre des économistes
atterrés également mes recherches sa
porte sur les questions de développement
de soutenabilité du développement
question de pouvoir et puis avec un
focus sur l'économie keynésienne puisque
c'est un peu mon auteur de prédilection
indirectement viendra science au sujet
des david et bien je suis également
économiste maître 21 et des lettres
qu'elle a
économiste maître de conférences à
l'université d'angers
je suis donc aussi l'un des membres des
économistes atterrés
méthane de recherche sont assez vastes
j'ai bon j'ai travaillé beaucoup sur la
crise européenne et maintenant je
m'intéresse à la manière dont l'économie
la société s'ajuste mutuellement enfin
comment est ce que le marché
s'insère dans la société et comment
parfois il peut détruire la société
c'est toute la question que qui
m'intéresse à d'autres sociétés qui s'en
sert dans le marché non
oui en fait aujourd'hui c'est ça sert
concrètement c'est la la la au lieu que
ce soit de marché que soit contrôlée par
la société c'est là c'est le marché qui
contrôle la société les économistes
atterrés c'est quoi
c'est un collectif qui s'est créé à la
suite de la crise de 2008 je sais pas si
vous souvenez mais en 2008 on a eu
un florilège d'économistes
que nous on classe comme un économiste
libéraux qui se
qui ont été très serrés de la crise qui
ne l'ont pas vu venir et qui ont dit
qu'ils en ont appelé à une régulation
de l'économie des marchés des marchés
financiers en particulier d'où est venue
la crise
à une moralisation du capitalisme en
fait on a eu un certain nombre de choses
comme ça d'effets de manche comment
d'effets de manche en fait la suite de
l'histoire le dira mais à l'époque c'est
vrai qu'on a eu une sorte de soulèvement
s'est dit nous qui sommes quand même
économistes critiquent hétérodoxes sedee
est peut-être que les choses sont en
train de changer la pensée unique en
économie
commence à se fissurer
et patatrac renversement en 2010
les dettes publiques étant assez élevé
les marchés financiers se retourne et
on attend on entend des politiques
on voit des politiques se mettre en
place des politiques d'austérité et
c'est suite à ce choc de sidération pour
nous c'est à dire que de n'avoir rien
appris de ce qui s'est passé en 2008
et même d'une certaine manière ces
politiques d'austérité font suite en
fait tout ce qui s'est passé avant et
dans une forme d' accélération du
capitalisme tel qu'il est en fait on a
créé il ya eu un manifeste le premier
manifeste d'économistes atterrés qui
dénonce en fait les idées reçues de la
pensée des économistes libéraux
les marchés sont efficients par exemple
pour comprendre il y en a plein d'autres
skis ski et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ce qui s'est passé à partir de 2008
2009 c'est que le monde était au bord de
la rupture les ya vu la faillite de
lehman brothers tout le monde était
paniqué on avait président nicolas
sarkozy qui disait les paradis fiscaux
c'est terminé et on a mené des
politiques étaient des pratiques
totalement différent de régulation de la
finance et des banques et
d'interventions massives des états et
aux à peine un an et demi plus tard ben
c'est oublié on reprend les politiques
qui avait mené au cas auparavant donc le
vrai problème c'est le manifeste il
vient il vient d'une comment dire du
d'une forme de révolte contre le retour
aux politiques qui avait mené à la crise
en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
interprétés et donc on dit rappelez-vous
1 vous avez vu que le marché n'était pas
efficace vous avez vu la crise l'arrivée
la faillite de lehman brothers à tout ce
qui s'est passé vous avez appelé les
états au secours des banques et
maintenant vous vous êtes en train
d'affaiblir à nouveau les états vous
êtes en train de de revenir sur des
logiques d'austérité qui vont forcément
ré entraîner une crise donc le le coeur
du propos des comices intérêt c'est de
dire ce que vous aviez dit en 2009
c'était pas si faux et maintenant il
faut tenir compte et il n'est pas
revenir aux politiques pré crise eric
c'est quoi les préconisations des
économistes atterrés c'est de se poser
toutes les politiques dites néolibérale
que l'on voit mise en oeuvre depuis
depuis une bonne trentaine d'années
maintenant
d'abord justement dans les pays en
développement depuis le début des années
80 ans 82 il y avait une grave crise de
la dette qui a donné lieu à la mise en
place de ce que l'on a appelé le
consensus de washington s'était en fait
des politiques économiques un ensemble
de politiques économiques qui faisait
consensus à washington c'est à dire les
autorités américaines les grandes
institutions internationales que sont le
fonds monétaire international et la
banque mondiale par exemple et avec
voilà donc avec toujours les mêmes
recettes n'y avait rien de bien nouveau
désengagement de l'état austérité
budgétaire
libéralisation financière qui a vu le
jour qui s'est développée dans les
années 80 pour être totalement effective
au début des années 90 et qui sont à
l'origine de
la crise financière qui se répètent
justement depuis les années 90
les politiques de déréglementation les
politiques de compétitivité on y
reviendra peut-être peut-être ton
interprétation
notamment l'interprétation parce que
cyclique des crises les crise de 2008 a
été créée par coin mais la crise de 2008
c'est une crise de la dette privée
c'est une crise de la dette privée des
ménages américains les plus pauvres et
qui s'est caractérisée donc la crise des
subprimes donc c'était les marchés du
crédit c'est la titrisation de séléné
les marchés du crédit hypothécaire du
marché immobilier à des crédits
immobiliers voilà hypothécaires donc
avec le fameux rêve américain il faut
que tout le monde puisse accéder à la
propriété etc etc sauf que depuis le
début des années 80 les revenus des
ménages les plus pauvres ont diminué
mais comme il faut quand même consommé
pour maintenir un niveau de consommation
et pour accéder à son logement on a
développé une activité de d'endettement
est ce que tu a identifié un élément
réseautique extérieur qui aurait pu
déclencher cette crise comme par exemple
prix du pétrole à 50 747 90 le baril à
cette époque là à l'époque oui c'est
vrai qu'il ya aussi en 2007 au moment la
crise c'est eux la hausse de tous les
prix des matières premières on a eu
aussi je me souviens les révoltes de la
faim
voilà mes mais de mon point de vue ça ça
touchait pas les états unis typiquement
les foudres est il faut voir aussi que
même au moment du pic des chocs
pétroliers et enfin de ce choc pétrolier
le
le prix de l'essence finalement ou dans
les revenus des ménages dans dans le pib
américain était finalement assez faible
et beaucoup plus faibles qu'en 73 au
moment du premier choc pétrolier c'est à
dire que je pense pas que ce soit le
coeur de la crise en faite le après
évidemment ça c'est un débat une
discussion qu'on peut avoir mais on a
quand même une ingénierie financière qui
c'est qui s'est développée à partir des
années 2000 qui a consisté à titriser
ces crédits mobiliers donc ça veut dire
en fait et on les a mis en papier et on
a revendu ses papiers sous la forme avec
tes ce qu'on appelle les special purpose
vehicule c'est à dire d d d entreprise
basée offshore qui émettait des
obligations est donc le souci c'est que
les acheteurs d'obligations il savait
que c'était du crédit mobilier mais
connaissait pas la qualité ce crédit
immobilier ce qui s'est passé
concrètement dans sa créance dans cette
crise et que du coup on pouvait avoir
des des crédits immobiliers de bonne
qualité en gros des prêts aux ménages
qui ont enfin des classes moyennes
moyennes supérieures qui rembourse le
taux de défaut est très très faible et
très faible aux états unis à sa mort à
ce moment-là et et on pouvait aussi
avoir des crédits immobiliers qui
étaient accordés à des ménages qui
n'avait pas du tout les moyens souvent
des fioretti miller le team n'était venu
absents en fait les il y avait eu aucune
capacité de savoir pour se cacher les
obligations qu'elle était la base sous
jacent de ses obligations et ce qu'ils
étaient sur des crédits pourris haut ce
qui se dit c'est bon crédit parce qu'on
est tous mélangés et le problème c'est
qu'au bout d'un an ça veut dire qu'il
est plus d'incitations à faire des bons
crédits donc ce qui s'est passé à paris
en 2004 2005 c'est que l'essentiel des
crédits immobiliers et les crédits
subprimes des mauvais crédits et est en
fait ils ont fini par contaminer tout le
monde et quand j'ai vu le taux de défaut
qui est passé de 5% à 15% eh bien on
s'est aperçu que tout explose et
concrètement les obligations on n'avait
aucune idée dorn de leur rendement réel
on savait pas séparer les bonnes des
mauvaises que tout ça était totalement
mélanger et comme
les etats unis ont une balance
commerciale déficitaire
ça veut dire que leur épargne et racheté
enfin aux états unis l'ailé en gros les
c'est plutôt que les les étrangers
financent voilà plutôt les périodes de
temps à nous deux une via un haut taux
d'épargné très faible niveau
d'endettement qui est très très élevé et
donc ce qui se passe c'est que les les
les américains pour financer ces crédits
en fait ils ont exporté leurs titres de
dettes et donc et il devrait se
retrouver dans les banques et dans les
bilans des banques du monde entier et là
quand on quand la crise s'est avéré et
bien en fait on a eu des faillites
bancaires astronomique est ce qu'on
appelle un credit crunch c'est-à-dire
les banques ont arrêté de prêter elles
ont arrêté de prêter entre elles tout le
système de financement mondial s'est
arrêté avant le fait que la russie la
chine en ce moment seuls de cette cible
ce qu'est ce que tu en penses seul
parent et en vendre c'est thibault se
maintient à
ckoi antibes ou alors c'est les cds
obligations alors je ne sais pas
thibault les bons du trésor ok bons du
trésor ils sont publics américains
cdc les obligations publiques
américaines
j'avoue que
il ya effectivement un problème
aujourd'hui les marchés financiers sont
à un niveau très élevé ils sont très
très cher donc on se pose la question
l'économie américaine est en fin de
cycle donc on se demande s'ils décident
deux ou trois ans on va pas y avoir de
nouvelle crise financière et donc
l'impact l'impact est bien les taux
d'endettement enfin l'endettement
américain il est quand même assez élevé
d'endettement public américain est assez
élevé et il pourrait y avoir
comment dire un ca pour est de nature à
en gros les et eni pourrait faire à
défaut pourrait pourrait éventuellement
faire un défaut je pense que c'est ça
qui craignent eux
bon moi je pense pas que j'aurais pu
dealer nette
baisse quand même chose enfin
concrètement un défaut des fous ici la
répudiation de la dette et dans leur
constitution oui ou non
les ménages privés peuvent le faire mais
la question en fait pour moi à l'état
souverain il peut toujours faire défaut
en fait que ce soit dans la constitution
ou non absolument il est souverain et
peut dire je vous rembourse pas le
problème c'est que c'est pas très simple
à gérer après dans le long terme si les
états unis font défaut qui c'est qui va
leur prêter après moi moi je pense la
dette publique américaine n'est pas si
élevé que cela concrètement par rapport
au dynamisme de l'économie américaine la
hauteur de combien aujourd'hui aller
supérieur à 100% du pib mais les états
il est alors je ne connais pas le
chiffre exact mais on est supérieur à
100% c'est clair moins de 150 fin entre
entre les deux fois supérieure à dix
mille milliards de données mais
concrètement
concrètement la des pays qui sont bien
plus endettés que ça et l'économie
américaine reste une économie hyper
dynamique les etats unis aussi la
première à main armée mondiale ils ont
déjà en quelque part fait défaut
lorsqu'ils ont renoncé fait que le
dollar américain
cci les mythes non pas par la banque
centrale américaine et par le trésor feu
doux voilà non non pas le trésor
américain pas par le ministère des
finances justement c'est différent des
autres systèmes des systèmes monétaires
et donc quand le trésor américain comme
nixon dis je je je ne rassurent plus la
convertibilité du dollar en or et bien
en fait c'est une forme de défaut en
quelque sorte voilà ça n'a pas empêché
les américains finalement après de
revenir enfin ils n'ont pas perdu leur
place de première puissance économique
eric le japon tout dans notre nom de
156% oui et ça pose pas ça leur pose pas
de propane ça peut poser des problèmes
mais actuellement ce n'est pas le
problème principal du japon parce que le
le japon a cette particularité qu'une
bonne partie de sa dette est détenue par
des japonais par des plus qu'un maintenu
par des résidents peut-être un peu moins
mais c'est quand même majoritairement
majoritairement le cas et dans ce cas là
là
la gestion de la question de la dette
est un peu un peu moins difficile on va
dire entre guillemets puisque ça revient
à une question de répartition de la
richesse c'est à dire que l'état
japonais peut dire tiens je j'augmente
les impôts sur les plus riches japonais
qui sont détenteurs de mad est donc je
leur prends je leur prends un peu pour
les rembourser de l'autre côté et la
question du remboursement de la dette
quand la dette est dite interne
c'est plutôt une question de répartition
ou de meilleure répartition de la
richesse
ça pose problème quand les créanciers
sont des créanciers externe peu le cas
de la grèce par exemple dont on a
beaucoup parlé ces dernières années les
grecs soit 180 % de dette rapporté alors
leur pib
eux ça leur pose des problèmes parce que
leurs principaux créanciers sont des
banques françaises des banques
allemandes et ce sont elles qui dictent
qui dicte la conduite à tenir ça qu'on
va sauver la grèce pour sauver la
société générale ou le même pays arbre
est clairement oui parce que de toute
façon depuis les premiers plans de
sauvetage grec l'an 2010 et à peu près à
peu près 90% des sommes qui ont été
prêtés à la grèce ont servi à rembourser
les créanciers de la grèce
principalement comme j'ai dit des
banques françaises des banques attendent
ça servait à rien de se couvrir sur la
grèce cantons prennent la dette grecque
a en fait
c'était big book ou non plus beau
une restructuration partielle de la
dette enfin ils n'ont pas vraiment perdu
parce que les titres s'échangeaient à un
niveau tel aviv qu'il parle un peu trop
d'espoir les mirettes plaisir
enfin
enfin moi ce que je voudrais dire
peut-être plus généralement parce que tu
as posé la question de
d'où ça venait en 2008 et effectivement
on peut rechercher à l'augmentation du
prix du pétrole
l'évolution sectorielle enfin du marché
de l'immobilier aux états unis mais ce
qu'il faut quand même
essayer de faire si longue absence d'un
contexte historique dans lequel en fait
les crises financières sont de plus en
plus nombreuses depuis que les marchés
financiers ont été dits libéralisé mais
dans les faits ils sont largement co
construit par les tirs réguliers
dérégulé dérégulé des régulations sont
sont le fait des politiques
bien précise du secteur bancaire et du
secteur des marchés financiers dans les
années
90 et en particulier aux états unis
avant mais en 90 en europe qui
permettent une plus grande mobilité du
capital en fait ce qu'on appelle la
liquidité capital et plus de ce capital
et liquides et s'échange de tout de
toutes les manières possibles dans tous
les pays du monde plus effectivement on
voit arriver des crises financières de
plus en plus régulièrement les crises
financières qui peuvent être
relativement sectorielle voilà qui peut
avoir des effets plus ou moins localiser
ou effectivement les dernières crises
sont des crises celle de 2008 est une
des plus importantes et elles avaient en
tout cas elle a montré un visage qui
pouvait être une crise systémique qui a
été arrêtée fermement puisque les états
se sont engagés
pour éponger les dettes donc mais avec
de l'eau d'être comment avec de la dette
avec de la dette oui c'est surtout bon
voilà exemple au futur elles ont sauvé
les banques un finalement ils ont sauvé
le système sans résoudre le problème fut
aussi longtemps que tu attends un peu
plus de style direct à ce moment là je
pense que c'est parce que c'est une
question possible que si du lot c'est la
séparation des activités
dans une banque les activités de
spéculation des atypiques et les
activités d'investissement et les
activités classiques d'une banque qui
fait des crédits auprès soit des ménages
pour les entreprises qu'on n'a pas fait
mais bon ils ont réparti fait ils ont en
partie raison en partie revenu sur la
libéralisation totale puisque
avant la première une des premières
décisions qui ont été prises par la fed
c'est de permettre
d'assurer aussi les banques
d'investissement normalement la fed
assure que les banques de dépôt est en
fait ils ont permis enfin ils ont les
banques d'investissement comme lehman
brothers s'était des banques avait perdu
beaucoup d'argent et il y avait des
risques étaient très importants et elles
ont dû à nouveau être régulée par la fed
pour profiter d'un accepté d'être régulé
par la fin de profiter de l'assurance de
la fed et ulloa bancaire qui est passé
aux états unis quelques quelques années
après je connais plus les termes exacts
mais qui
recontrôle en partie
les banques américaines il ya eu plus il
est plus de régulation aux états unis
qui en a eu en france et en europe en
réalité il faut noter c'est bien c'est
intéressant de montrer c'est que souvent
on a l'image un peu faux enfin en
l'occurrence pour le pour le cas
d'espèce un peu fausse comme quoi les
états unis seraient toujours le
l'endroit où il ya plus de
libéralisation de dérégulation et c est
en fait en europe et en france
le gouvernement hollandais a été élu sur
un programme dans lequel il était
inscrit effectivement à une loi de
séparation du secteur bancaire entre ces
deux activités et il a accouché d'une
souris d'une toute petite souris puisque
c'est une loi qui filiale ea c'est à
dire qu'il demande aux banques de mettre
en filiales dans activités spéculatives
qui je crois
à un conduit un filialiser que 2% des
activités des banques donc en fait
ce qui ce qu'on a fait en france est
très très très en dessous de ce qui a
été proposé aux états unis et même en
dessous de la volonté de régulation en
tout cas de contrôle a minima de la
commission européenne dont d'éminents
situation ici en france je dirais on a
quand même il nous faut un fort lobbying
bancaire très près de bercy qui joue
absolument là une très forte dé
régulation des systèmes financiers en
france plus particulièrement par rapport
aux autres pays européens
le lobby bancaire est très puissant et
donc on a un capitalisme relativement
financiarisé par rapport par exemple à
l'allemagne
même si effectivement la
financiarisation c'est à dire la la la
la
déréglementation des marchés financiers
la transformation des entreprises sous
le mode de cette financiarisation est
moins important en allemagne par exemple
que ce n'est le cas en france rick
la france est le pays qui au niveau de
l'union européenne freine des quatre
fers pour empêcher toute mise en place
d'une taxe sur les transactions
financières pourquoi justement parce que
ce lobby ce lobby bancaire et financier
très puissant et lui veut pas en
entendre parler il veut pouvoir manuel
da cruz il peut pas dire bon c'est ce
film c'est un ancien banquier chez
rothschild et il pourrait 1 mais je
pense qu'il ne veut absolument pas
enfin il ya plein de signaux qui
montrent ça je sais pas je prends un
exemple la réforme de l'impôt sur la
fortune de li sf transformer en impôt
sur la fortune immobilière qu'est ce
qu'il a il
recadre ça sur les biens immobiliers
mais sur les titres financiers sur le
compte de ce qu'on appelait les valeurs
mobilières là elles sont plus taxées bon
là la taxation la flatte fameux flat tax
à 30% également sur le sur le capital ce
sont des signaux qui vont à linverse de
d'un processus qui viserait à introduire
cette fameuse taxe tobin cette taxe sur
les transactions financières et la
france est vraiment un pays un des pays
européens si c'est le pays européen qui
freine le plus pour empêcher ça parce
que peut-être le système financier
bancaire français a besoin
d'éviter de se faire taxer parce que
sinon ils tombent non ils préservent
leurs marges et préserve quoi
similaire à tous les pays a pas de
raison que le problème le premier qu'on
est dans la concurrence c'est-à-dire
concrètement si un pays commencent à
taxer sont épargnés bien les parcs va
aller dans un autre pays donc des
sources de haut niveau européen voilà
mais le problème là le problème les
banques françaises sont particulièrement
touchés parce que on a un régime on est
spécialisé dans son appel la banque
universelle c'est-à-dire une banque qui
fait à la fois de l'assurance du crédit
aux ménages du crédit aux entreprises
qu'elles font des opérations de marché
et donc et donc la taxe sur les
transactions financières elle est plus
pesé sur les banques françaises que sur
les banques locales italiennes ou
d'autres pays qui sont qui sont pas
tellement financiarisé nous que nous on
a quand même fait lire bnp a racheté
paribas donc bnp banque de dépôt a
racheté paribas banque d'affaires la
société générale a créé ces salles de
marché et avoue souvenu souvenez de la
faire l affaire kerviel donc on à elles
sont toutes ont fait de l'assurance
puisque maintenant il ya tous les tous
les assureurs ont des banques et vice
versa et donc faire des taxes sur les
transactions financières c'est la taxe
est en fait la partie financière ça
allait plus pesé sur les banques
généralistes que sur des bancs que dans
des états ou des pays dans lesquels les
banques sont restées spécialisés raison
de plus pour mettre en oeuvre cette
séparation entre et bien sûr parce qu'on
n'a pas du tout c'est pareil parce qu'on
peut pas notre modèle en clair il y
avait sur
comment dire là on a vraiment les
assureurs les banques et les opérations
de marché et ça ça a permis d'ailleurs
aux banques françaises est très efficace
et très par rapport aux autres banques
on a plutôt bien résisté à la crise en
france les banques alors qu'elles
avaient un taux de solvabilité qui
étaient très faibles parmi les plus
faibles d'europe pourquoi parce qu'elles
sont hyper diversifiée le problème c'est
que quand un système diversifié fait
faillite tout s'effondre en même temps
les rayonnages qu'est ce qu'on pense de
bâle bâle 2 bâle iii ça va finir dans un
trou c'est un homme
je ne sais pas je connais un petit peu
bon en gros c'est des systèmes de
régulation
en fait les règles de bâle s'est laissé
les agences bancaires internationales
qui décident s'autoréguler en fait il
peut aussi une question de
de fou nous avons un peu justement c'est
ce qu'a pensé ça donc l'auteur il est
relancé et tranquille
mais l'auto régulation des bucks et
éviter en fait qu'une banque trop
importante fasse faillite et entraîne
avec elle toutes les autres banques
c'est qu'on appelle le risque systémique
est donc pour ça voilà les leçons sont
réunis en suisse à bâle c'est pas pour
rien que c'est la suisse et l ont essayé
de se mettre des règles de procédure un
pour dire bon ben voila quand on prête
il faut calculer le risque est donc
quand qui ont mis un risque il faut
mettre en réserve un peu d'argent donc
ça c'est les règles sur la base des
règles de bâle à lyon fait les malins et
balens a pas plu notamment grandes
banques qui dit oui mais ces règles sont
trop rigides il faut que l'on puisse
nous les banques organiser nous-mêmes
nos fins nous nos évaluations rien n'y a
pas on peut pas avoir tous la même
évaluation sinon on va tous faire ils
ont la même souche et l'évaluation et
donc elles ont le droit de s'auto
évaluer en quelque sorte que ça c'était
bâle ii et bâle ii est arrivé en 2007 au
moment de la crise donc là évidemment ça
n'a pas empêché la crise donc du coup on
s'est dit il faut faire bâle iii en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que à chaque fois
ce sont d'abord les banques c'est des
règles sont émises par les banques pour
s'autoréguler en quelque sorte et qui
sont allés banques pour le goupe voilà
par exemple les banques et qui sont
ensuite validées à l'échelle européenne
ou les châles américaine et celle des
pays bon plutôt en europe à l'échelle
européenne et qui sont mises dans le
temps dans le droit et est donc on est
toujours sur cette logique là leur bâle
iii vise à réparer les défauts de bâle 2
qui vivait à améliorer les problèmes de
bâle 1 mais concrètement à partir du
moment où c'est des règles que les
banques se donne à elle même ça ne
semble pas être une épée régulation et
bien sûr que l'objectif de ces banques
c'est quand même de ceux s'autoréguler
mais en même temps pas trop réguler pour
pouvoir contenir les projets une petite
parenthèse en une question internet
qui vient de tomber est ce que les
invités pourraient développer leur leur
opinion sur la loi pompidou giscard ou
la loi de 1973 quels sont les avantages
de cette fois lorsqu'elle a été passée
en dix bons joueurs ça doit être un gars
de l'upper qui a passé sa nuit
des masques aller mais c'est la dernière
campagne
je vais en dire un peu plus peut-être
d'aller compléter mais c'est le sait le
début de en fait la dette publique
quant au canton et à aimer enfin besoin
effectivement de financer une dette il
peut le faire globalement de moyens soit
s'adresser à sa banque centrale ce qu'on
appelle le monétiser la dette c'est à
dire je suis bien la planche à billets
elle soit effectivement s'adresser aux
marchés financiers et 73 c'est le début
d'une obligation faite à aux états de
s'adresser beaucoup plus aux marchés
financiers - la banque centrale mais si
je me souviens bien c'était pas une
obligation stricte c'est à dire que 73
n'est pas le l'obligation totale faite à
l'état français de s'adresser aux
marchés financiers c'est une
diversification de la delà de la source
de financement de la dette publique
française la vraie rupture c'est
maastricht 192 ou effectivement la
création du marché unique et de l'euro à
terme
obliger les états à se financer sur les
marchés financiers pour la raison
suivante c'est de dire si l'état sont
financés sur les marchés financiers ils
seront évalués par les marchés
financiers non de manière rationnelle et
cette manière rationnelle permettra
est-ce que lier pas des dettes laxiste
des gouvernants
sous le sou à la recherche
[Musique]
des lecteurs conduisent effectivement
augmenté la dette de manière
inconsidérée à faire de la subornation
de vote on crée on a des publics pour
proposer des emplois publics c'est ça
mais c'est ans qui a fait un peu ce
qu'il fait le parti socialiste pendant
35 ans qu'est ce qui est paradoxal dans
l'histoire c'est que c'était euro ont
contraint les états à se financer
exclusivement sur les marchés financiers
en disant bon comme tu comme dirait bien
de le dire on voit mieux les surveiller
ils feront moins n'importe quoi parce
que l'état par définition pour les
libéraux ils gaspillent il utilise mal
l'argent enfin bon et s'est exprimée
rossouw qui arrive à la tête de l'état
sont ceux qui font de la subornation de
vote en faisant des grandes promesses
oui ans et en ayant et on va dire en
basant leur autorité de subornation de
vote par de la dette non mais si on
regarde sur les allées les vingt
dernières années si on regarde si on
regarde les gouvernements de droite et
de gauche qui se succèdent et les vôtres
et l'évolution du oui non mais
l'évolution de la dette et la dette
souvent elles augmentent beaucoup plus
sous les gouvernements de droite confère
balladur à l'époque
concrètement les les dernières dépenses
publiques qui ont été fait c'était pour
les entreprises c'est pas pour les
électeurs le cec km on sent très
longtemps les réductions de charges sur
les entreprises celles des années 90 et
pour
juste une chose la grande crainte des
libéraux si c'est l'inflation et donc
c'était ça la monétisation de la dette
c'est-à-dire la le financement de
2 du budget va du déficit budgétaire de
l'état via la banque centrale dont via
la création monétaire est supposé créer
de l'inflation et sa l'inflation les
libéraux l'ont en horreur parce que ça
rogne alors l épargne donc saron les
revenus de l'épargné des plus riches ça
vous fait d'être mais ça ne m'est bien
sûr mais ça bouffe la dette bien sûr
mais ça à la limite il s'en fiche de qui
est un peu plus de dette puisque
généralement sont les vins qui sont
créanciers de l'état
il faut revenir quand même un peu sur le
contexte de 73 quand cette loi est votée
parce que je trouve qu'on les prenne
beaucoup à cette loi on fête les chocs
pétroliers 73 73 mais c'est aussi alors
ses dix ans ils ont conduit pétrole
massey 71
non parce que le coeur le coeur des
problèmes on a une demi d'activité c'est
l'augmentation du coût énergétique le
temps russe oui mais le coeur du
problème en fait il à 2,71 donc avant le
choc pétrolier s'est justement nixon qui
décident de suspendre la convertibilité
du dollar en or est donc sacré désordre
monétaire en fait ça va être de 71 76
les avoir une paire de désordres
monétaires là dessus c'est vrai il ya le
choc pétrolier mais la loi est votée le
1er janvier 73 donc en fait bien avant
le géant pétrolier puisque ce précieux
auprès arrivera après tout ce n'est pas
une réponse le champ pétrolier est une
réponse aux problèmes monétaires de
l'époque et auprès de monétaire de
l'époque c'est une supputation aux
anneaux ah non c'est à dire que
concrètement on ne peut pas anticiper on
1er janvier 73 on veut pas anticiper le
choc pétrolier personne n'y croira ce
moment là c'est celle ci revient que la
guerre du kippour le programme
thermonucléaire il vient de condamner
ben ils commencent commence tôt mais il
est vraiment mise en oeuvre que par
giscard soit 14 mai avant évidemment il
ya un programme mais mais si je reviens
sur sur sur la loi 73 le problème il est
con on assiste à partir du début des
années 70 justement à une montée de
l'inflation et cette inflation ne va
cesser d'augmenter dans un sens 10
jusqu'à devenir devenir très importante
au début des années 80 on va toucher du
taux d'inflation à plus de 10% alors
bien sûr que le choc pétrolier il agit
sur l'inflation parce que concrètement
quand les prix du pétrole augmentent
dans une économique et très d'épreuves
dépendance au pétrole ça fait augmenter
tous les prix mais mais mais il y avait
précédemment il y avait justement la
remise en cause par nixon en 71 de la
deux
du taux de conversion de lui la
convertibilité du dollar en or est donc
le problème c'est qu'on arrive
progressivement vers un système
monétaire international ou où les taux
de change sont plus rigides y sont ils
deviennent totalement flexible décidée
par les marchés et donc là les états il
faut qu'ils défendent leur monnaie il
faut qu'ils défendent leurs monnaies
pour défendre leur épingle pour éviter
l'inflation et donc le problème il est
puisque eric l'a rappelé que dans les
théories des économies de l'époque mais
aujourd'hui encore une beaucoup
d'économistes croient à sa
toute inflation a une origine monétaire
c'est à dire qu'on crée trop de monnaie
or comment créer trop de monnaie et ben
en partie par la monétisation de la
dette donc l'idée pour moi en tout cas
la raison pour laquelle on a pour voter
cette loi c'était pour alors pas empêché
la monétisation puisque comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure l'état a continué
d'utiliser sa banque centrale pour
encore des circuits de financement par
la banque centrale après 113 oms a pas
totalement mis fin à ça mais l'idée
était aussi de quelque part je pense en
tout cas de rassurer les investisseurs
de leur dire regardez on va pas faire la
dette n'importe comment la banque
centrale va pas racheter toute la dette
des états
et en gros montré que le franc
restez donner confiance offrant aux
moments où justement tout le système
international était en train de
s'effondrer sous votre parenthèses la
bce en ce moment qui rachète toutes les
obliques pourri de le terrain en europe
elle est en train de se transformer en
bad bank ou pas moi je pense a pas
beaucoup de sens
disons qu'on
est là elle a un sens les économistes de
gauche là les gars ça veut dire c'est
une banque c'est pas une banque
ne peut pas faire faillite c'est pas une
banque ou c'est pas une banque comme les
autres parce que c'est par elle peut pas
faire face
si elle fait faillite elle emmène tout
le monde par le fond c'est ça
qui en dernier et créatrice de la
monnaie donc si elle a besoin de monnaie
qu'elle a de la monnaie à la craie
l'inflation alors parfois qu'ils soient
forcément est par exemple depuis je me
suis dit ah mais non mais de la bce qui
inondent les noms des marchés financiers
de liquidités depuis plusieurs années
mais on devrait avoir une inflation de
dingue pourquoi elle ne fait pas parce
qu ici elle annonce qu'elle inonde à
l'externalisation d'un et ça et ça ne
génère pas d'inflation parce que cette
relation là théorique qui ancien un qui
a été qui a été fort mal y résident et
du 19e siècle et qui a été formalisée au
début du 20e siècle par un économiste
américain qui s'appelait irving fisher
et cette relation là qui fait donc d'une
causalité entre la création monétaire et
l'inflation ça ne fonctionne pas là là
les politiques monétaires de la banque
centrale européenne aujourd'hui la lèze
qu'on appelle le quantitative easing
donc c'est à dire justement là 2001
mario voilà je rachète dette publique
fin de tout tout tout ça est fait pour
quoi est fait pour faire marcher cette
théorie à l' inverse c'est à dire trop
de création monétaire engendre de
l'inflation le problème actuel en europe
au sein d'union au sein de la zone euro
c'est justement qu'on est proche de la
déflation c'est à dire une inflation
négative à ce qu'on passera par la
stagnation votre doux pas forcément donc
verser ma compassion c'est autre chose
l'adaptation des traditions nation
économique définition avec de
l'inflation qu'est ce que c'est voilà
c'est la coexistence le train de
l'information une jauge qui se traduit
par contre pour tous les jours des gens
les communes people mais qui sait ce
qu'il ce qui développe c'est que il ya
une création ont été très importantes
fait de la part de l'un des banques
centrales mais cette création monétaire
ne se répercute pas sur les prix j'ai
dit rehn estime et biens et des services
classiques c'est-à-dire dans le
quotidien on ne voit pas effectivement
de grosse inflation par contre on a une
inflation sur les marchés financiers
c'est à dire que les actifs ça crée des
bulles en fait cette cette quantité de
monnaie vient nourrir les toutes les
toutes les spéculations possibles les
derniers par exemple les droits du foot
ou des choses comme ça on a des bulles
comme ça qui est qui qui ne font que
rendre les crises futures toujours plus
importantes et toujours plus plus
dangereuses ou de la concentration de
pouvoirs avec sookie souffre tout à fait
bien peu là on parle économie je te
laisse de l'énergie mais justement enfin
même pense qu'il faut aussi contrôler de
l'asile comment toi qui es qui a créé un
master de psychologie d'économies est ce
que les fous pris le contrôle de l'asile
on pourrait penser non il ya une forme
d'aveuglément de il ya ne sais pas si
c'est un cynisme on aveuglement mais en
tout cas les élites politiques
économiques actuelles mégalomanie de la
mégalomanie il ya 200 ans mais je pense
que moi je pense qu'il ya il ya comme
une
[Musique]
une fuite en avant eux mêmes une rupture
par rapport à des élites politiques qui
était qui étaient là avant etc je pense
que les élites politiques actuelles ont
fait aux portes de sécession je dirais
avec la société c'est le mot qui me
vient le plus pour moi le plus expressif
qui montre que finalement ils sont
tellement convaincus c'est pas qu'ils
sont cyniques ou sont tellement
convaincus de la théorie de leur mode de
pensée et cetera ils ont les moyens
aussi d'aller jusqu'au bout les moyens
financiers tu l'as dit les moyens
technologiques
qui a une course en avant qui s'accélère
et donc c'est vrai qu'on sent comme une
session c'est à dire quelque chose qui
fait que même si dans la société on voit
se dégrader les penchants tiers dans les
banlieues des classes le des classes
populaires etc détention etc ben ils
sont plus touchés concrètement part ça
ça c'est vrai que ne semble que c'est
l'époque actuelle est marquée par cette
session c'est une religion
oui c'est une forme de religion dans ce
sens là dans le sens de quelque chose
qui serait la vérité révélée des marchés
tout est fondé sur l'idée que finalement
les marchés la concurrence c'est
l'efficience même c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas l'éviter et 7 non remise en
question de l'efficience qu'est ce que
ce l'efficience l'efficience pourquoi
dans quel but politique pour quelle
finalité philosophique etc tout ça n'est
pas n'est pas donné c'est quelque chose
qui est transcendantale qu'on pouvait
être dieu c'est bon et dur est bon il à
l'efficience des marchés est bonne elle
n'est pas à questionner ce qui a
questionné c'est pour eux c'est en deçà
de sa c'est à dire on peut questionner
effectivement les effets de cette
efficience donc on peut y limiter les
effets tel endroit ou tel autre endroit
mais on questionne pas la question de
l'efficience des marchés elle est
question de l'efficience de la
concurrence de vide
non mais c'était la question de s que
les fouilles ont pris le contrôle de
l'asile ce qui est ce que je trouve
amusant c'est enfin moi je souscris à
tout ce que vient de dire mireille mais
ce que je trouve amusant c'est que en
fait ils sont ils ont ils ont très peur
en fait personne n'arrive à comprendre
ce qui va se passer parce que
typiquement le candidat qui visent in
glass est une solution de dernier
recours on savait pas quoi faire il
fallait remettre il fallait réussir à la
fois sauver les banques mais il fallait
aussi permettre aux états d'art est de
ne pas s'écrouler parce que ce qui s'est
passé c'est que la machine financière
enfin les le système bancaire en fait ce
qui s'est passé en 2008 c'est que on a
eu quelque chose qu'on connaissait dans
les manuels mais qu'on n'avait jamais vu
en vrai c'est à dire une crise
systémique une grande banque lehman
brothers qui a fait faillite et qui
entraîne dans son sillage la faillite
possible de tout le système bancaire
américain et du coup par là de tout le
système bancaire mondial donc c'est là
que les gouvernements
10 il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose il
faut qu'on sauve les créances et donc
qu'elle qu'ils font oui ils réagissent
enfin ils ne font pas ils sont pas là en
train de rationaliser de dire ah ben
tiens c'était prévu ils sont en train de
paniquer totalement et il sauve des
banques à igé aux états unis
voilà et ensuite la crise se propage
partout en europe et le système bancaire
se fige c'est-à-dire concrètement les
banques ne se font plus confiance
mutuellement donc elles se prêtent plus
donc elles ont plus de liquidités donc
la banque centrale européenne américaine
anglaise et sait comment c'est à dire
bon ben moi je joue mon rôle de prêteur
en dernier ressort si vous avez besoin
d'argent vous ne vous prêter plus entre
vous d'accord parce que vous faites plus
confiance puisque prêter à quelqu'un qui
va faire faillite évidemment ça pose
problème donc donc les banques centrales
disent allez-y vous avez guichet libre
tout ce que vous voulez emprunter vous
pouvez emprunter c'est là qu'apparaît la
monnaie en ce moment là c'est une
monnaie à court terme c'est la liquidité
alors à taux zéro mais c'est de la
monnaie à court terme mais après on se
dit oui mais le problème c'est cette
monnaie elle ne revient pas dans
l'économie se dire qu'en gros elles
restent dans le système bancaire donc
fait forcément veut pas faire d'
inflation puisque concrètement pour qui
est de l'inflation il faut que ça arrive
sur l'économie réelle il faut que ça
arrive sur les gens et surtout on arrive
après un deuxième moment c'est les
faillites ya une vraie inflation mais
sur les marchés financiers celle dont on
parle pas mais papa m'aime pas à ce
moment là parce qu'à ce moment là c'est
le des marchés financier s'écroule et et
c'est la liquidité c'est juste des s'est
passé ne peut pas utiliser cet argent
pour acheter des titres des titres
souverains et au contraire on à
l'effondrement des obligations publiques
européennes c'est-à-dire les taux
d'intérêt qui vont exploser en grèce en
irlande au mode pays et donc là à la
banque centrale européenne et la banque
fédérale américaine c'est pareil at il
dit il faut qu'on aille jusqu à la
rescousse de l'état des états parce que
les états eux mêmes n'arrivent plus à
emprunter donc elle va faire le candidat
teasing c'est à dire là elle a prêté aux
banques de l'argent
va acheter aux banques plus précisément
des obligations d'état avec de l'argent
créé ex nihilo par les banques centrales
ça c'est donc le cuit et donc ça permet
de faire augmenter sa douce augmentent
leurs
les achats d'actions d'obligations des
états et donc ça fait augmenter le prix
des obligations ça fait baisser les taux
d'intérêt et donc la deuxième partie le
deuxième volet c'est on va faire baisser
les taux d'intérêt partout alors le truc
c'est que les taux d'intérêt public elle
est notamment les taux d'intérêt à dix
ans il détermine les taux auxquels on
peut emprunter sur les marchés au
billiers les taux calorique que vous dit
quoi là dessus pas nommé ses complices
qui vient de dieu mais ce que je termine
juste sur le fait que les taux d'intérêt
sont donc tous à zéro à son moyen à long
terme à court terme et donc le problème
c'est quoi ça crée une inflation et là
je reviens ce que disait eric ça crée
une inflation du coup tous les
rendements sont faibles c'est à dire
concrètement une ax une obligation n'a
quasiment aucun rendement elles elles
arrivent même à des niveaux de rendement
qui sont négatifs donc donc les gens ils
vont commencer à essayer de trouver du
rendement donc ils vont commencer à
prendre des risques et c'est là qu'on va
voir l'explosion des marchés boursiers
qui va augmenter progressivement les
valeurs des marchés boursiers augmenté
on va acheter du bit kurier avoir une
bulle sur le bitcoin il ya quelques mois
et est donc et j'en viens la situation
pourquoi les gens sont fous et pourquoi
les gens se disent mais qu'est ce qu'on
va faire c'est que maintenant
concrètement on se dit il va y avoir une
nouvelle crise financière mais nos états
sont fragiles nos banques sont fragiles
le cul le camp dit yves easing ne peut
pas continuer de le faire comme ça si on
le savait taux d'intérêt sont 0 donc
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer qu'est ce
qu'on va avoir comme arme si jamais tout
ça s'effondre à nous faut stocker au
luxembourg ou non le projet de l'union
européenne c'est pareil c'est lui qui
sera promet le eric n'est perdu est ce
que ben bernanke jeannette il n est
maintenant qu'est-ce qui est la tête de
la fed la
cia vinatieri a
toujours la tête dit elle après les
remplacements parce qu'elle est l'alliée
toujours bons gènes et elle peut
augmenter les taux là ou pas c'est ça le
sait c'est ça le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui
il y aurait une volonté d'augmenter les
taux mais le problème c'est que si on
augmente les taux bas
fait défaut c'est génial is we are déjà
on relance la dette qui est déjà élevé
et puis on fera y en aura on freine
l'activité économique que l'on souhaite
relancer donc qui est déjà fragile donc
on est dans un des pieds poings liés la
baisse concerne tous par la barbichette
voilà exactement le premier qui est là
c'est qu'il a le poids de ce parti
police et la banque
ce qui ce qui trinqueront les premiers
bains c'est les classes sociales les
plus modestes comme d'habitude
ça peut être les épargnants aussi mais
pas forcément les plus importants parce
que je si tu permets juste rebondir sur
la question une petite question de
valeurs sûres ou est ce que c'est une
religion est ce que etc moi je pense je
pense qu'elle devrait lui une vraie
lutte des classes mais inversés c'est à
dire et d'ailleurs
les élites économiques s'en prive pas
warren buffett qui est un des grands
milliardaires américains au milieu des
années 2000 disait ouvertement que il y
avait une lutte des classes et que
c'était la sienne qui était en train de
la gagner voilà je me rappelle avoir
entendu françois fillon à leur premier
ministre dire qu'il est qu' il était en
train de gagner la bataille idéologique
donc il ya il ya
si on prend les questions sous cet angle
là soit un nombre de rapports de force
de domination de pouvoir de classe
contre autres alors évidemment c'est
difficile à définir une une classe de
façon très très fine mais les élites
économiques politiques et serrage à
l'épaule ça ne parle pas comment j'ai
une poubelle jérôme powell président de
la réserve fédérale des états unis 1er
février 2018 bon mais on n'était pas
joueur hockey bottine vent sur le bec
comme on dit au canard enchaîné mais
c'est la crème là on va commence
maintenant ok oui on a été gentils vous
avez s'est déployée mais on n'a
aucunement la prétention ah oui même en
tant qu'économiste daniel courtois avait
bien sûr mon parfum
profit serrières l'oeil du mal
là on a l'impression d'avoir fait
principalement les noms enfin je veux
dire c'est qu'ils important sinon ça va
devenir une interview à la chance
jacques bourdin on peut faire piéger
médias sur le diable sous le joug des
détails non non mais oui oui non mais
que ce soit monsieur powell ou yann et
jelen ou ben bernanke la politique la
politique monétaire américaine elle elle
change pas ces dernières années la nati
mais les voilà les problématiques sont
les mêmes mais bien sûr donc pour
revenir à la question de rapport de
force de lutte de classe on est aussi il
faut voir quand même on est dans cette
période néo libérale depuis la fin des
années 70 début des années 80 victoires
de maria raid thatcher au royaume uni de
ronald reagan aux états unis et les
valeurs qui sont mises en avant c'est la
compétition
l'individualisme l'égoïsme selon là
encore la vieille les vieilles idées
libérales du 19e siècle selon laquelle
le fait que chacun poursuivre son
intérêt personnel de façon égoïste va
par magie créé aboutir au bien commun ou
à l'intérêt général que la somme des
intérêts particuliers va faire l'intérêt
général ce qui est absolument faux mais
ce qui est une belle fable à raconter
pour dire tout le monde a sa chance etc
et permettre à ceux qui sont aux
manettes d'accroître leur pouvoir et de
faire peser sur les autres le
sont plus intelligents conséquence jeu
non non ils sont pas intelligents parce
qu'au final ils mettent en danger des
économies et ça leur retombera sur le
coin du nez à un moment ou un autre ils
sont plus intelligents et court terme
si être intelligent c'est gagner le plus
de pognon à court terme sur le dos des
autres ok ils sont très intelligents moi
je qualifierais passe intelligente je
dirais plutôt cynique dégueulasse
jan hommen par exemple oui non hors sol
or seuls prédateurs ah ben oui c'est sûr
we die aouine enfin je pense qu'il ya
quand même
ce qui est important par rapport à ce
qu'il a dit c'est de penser
qu'effectivement chacun et allah est à
la recherche sur l'intérêt privé chacun
accès qui était important ce qu'il ne
dit que bon il y avait plein d'autres
choses que je rebondis j'ai rebondi à ma
manière j'ai grandi sur ce que je dis
pas trop bien élevé ce que je veux dire
c'est que il ya une conception quand
même de l'individu qui est quand même
très particulière et on oublie souvent
de dire que à la base de tout c'est tout
c'est
finalement de cette civilisation mais
kiki mais c'est pas simplement va mettre
en danger effectivement les classes les
plus pauvres ça c'est évident mais même
jeudi rêve mais en danger l'humanité
dans son entièreté avec le réchauffement
climatique c'est à dire que tel que les
religions sont lancés actuellement
[Musique]
sur une île d'accord le changement de
modèle ce changement de paradigme ton
changement de paradigme tu vois comment
et quels sont les mesures opératif que
tu souhaites par exemple si je te donne
une baguette magique ça y est mireille
et présidente de la terre qu'est ce que
fait mireille j'espère être pas tout
seul parce que ça serait pour moi est ce
qu'il leur reste à ce qu'il me raye tu
réguler la démographie
ça peut-être alors ces événements c'est
piégeux mais c'est assez je prendrais
pas ça en premier voilà répondre à ce
article est-ce que tu le réguler ou
points non mais non évidemment il n'est
pas question d'avoir un gouvernement
mondial dans lequel quelqu'un décide de
la quantité des enfants fait renaître
donc je pense que ça prend aux dieux ah
tu crois en dieu non
pas du tout non mais mais par contre
je pense qu'il ya des mesures rapides à
faire effectivement il faut des
financiarisé il faut absolument
démonter ces immenses banques puissent
compter sur les marchés financiers il
faut des faits et financiarisé il faut
sectorisé les marchés financiers il faut
que le financement
du capital se fasse par des moyens
qu'ils soient pas des moyens qui sont
hors sol comme ça dans lesquelles tout
s'échange n'importe quand n'importe où
sans qu'on sache exactement ce cas
derrière
moi je suis en plus je vais beaucoup
plus loin je pense qu'il faut aussi
éviter que les entreprises de production
sur de trop grande taille pour éviter
qu'à l'intérieur des entreprises et des
phénomènes de domination de
rationalisation de travail qu'on connaît
depuis très longtemps qui ont été
dénoncés par max weber ou karl marx
d'ailleurs peu importe mais bon je pense
que tout ça
cette idée finalement fondamentale qui
traverse la la le capitalisme est
maintenant je dirais presque le monde
cette cité que quand ce plus grand c'est
toujours mieux
je pense que ça c'est à remettre en
question
si je peux je vous dis il mesure que je
prendrais bien encore plus radical c'est
la nationalisation des banques parce que
la monnaie c'est pas un bien privé la
signalisation ou là où la socialisation
des socialistes c'est ce que la
nationalisation des banques avec macron
en tant que chef de classe et cissé sait
pas si ça la nationalisation des banques
à condition d'avoir un état qui est pas
la macro ni où où est un avatar de la
macro en tout cas mais pourquoi pourquoi
la nationale voilà pourquoi la
nationalisation de la socialisation des
banques parce que la monnaie n'a pas
être un bien privé on a délégué la
gestion de la monnaie qui quand même
traversé tout le nos économies on se
serre tous de la monnaie la monnaie
c'est pas juste un intermédiaire des
échanges c'est une institution sociale
qui a introduit des liens justement
encore dans les rapports de force de
travail c'est un vecteur travail aussi
mais rappelons nous rappelons nous quand
même qu'au début des années 80 90 % du
système bancaire français étaient
publiques quel est l'avantagé d'un
système bancaire public ou socialisé
avec contrôle les inconvénients que sont
des inconvénients mais je suis d'abord
présenté les avantages parce que mon
avis y en a plus les avantages se sont
que sebbah ces banques là ne sont plus
tenus d'être gérées comme des comme
n'importe quelle entreprise privée sinon
une banque privée c'est une entreprise
privée son objectif faire du profit non
mais là une banque publique on peut lui
est assignée démission est évidemment
essayer de qu'elle soit qu'elles
n'agissent pas à perdre bien sûr mais
des missions dire financer la transition
écologique financer je sais pas des
choses qu'on aura jugé comme étant
important d'un point de vue collectif la
santé je veux que ces jours mais on met
les territoires l'agriculture voilà tu
réguler la démographie toi non moi je
serai sur la même position que mireille
alors je sais bien que il y avait par
exemple dans l'est le fameux de rapport
du club de rome donc des scientifiques
qui à la fin des années 60 travailler
sur la fin de la croissance dont qui a
donné lieu à la production d'un rapport
qui justement ça fait halte à la
croissance une mauvaise traduction
d'ailleurs parce qu en anglais c'était
aux limites du golfe mais le il avait
mis en avance à dix ans si on continue
avec le même système productiviste etc
si on fait pas attention voilà ici on
fait pas attention à la démographie on
courait à la catastrophe à l'horizon de
l'an 2000 c'est vrai que cette question
démographique est
problématique à traiter parce que si on
dit ce serait bien qu'on soit un peu
moins nombreux sur terre on être villes
du pays du tiers-monde non mais non puis
on avait été vite taxé d'eugénisme de
tout ce que l'on veut
voilà donc la transition démographique
elle se fait elle s'est faite voilà
c'est à dire que je veux dire c'est on
voit bien en tout cas que là la question
de la démographie elle peut pas être
prise par le haut
évidemment que si on doit affronter la
question écologique il faut penser à la
question de démographie mais
elle n'est pas à décider comme l'a fait
la chine un enfant par femme c'est par
contre accompagné l'émancipation des
femmes je pense que la contraception
après des familles les familles et des
fameux qui sont émancipés qui veulent
des diamants will et on sait que si on
voit bien que quand ça arrive
effectivement l'émancipation des fans là
la maîtrise des moyens de contraception
le taux de natalité diminue parce que
effectivement avoir quinze enfants je
sais pas si c'est un vrai projet de vie
pour une femme enfin en tout cas on peut
on peut on peut se poser la question
encore sur la démographie il ya le
pardon mais en fait il ya des loisirs
très simple qui réduit la démographie
sans réguler la démographie on sait très
bien que la démographie est fonction du
revenu par habitant on sait que ses
fonctions ah si quand même on sait que
ses fonctions de l'émancipation des
femmes de la scolarisation des femmes en
particulier tous les travaux de
démographe emmanuel todd le dise il ya
une transition démographique qui s'est
achevée au maghreb avec justement le
progrès l'éducation notamment
l'éducation supérieure et puis aussi le
système social c'est-à-dire le système
de retraite l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles on fait des gas c'est aussi
parce que on n'a pas de retraite et donc
il faut des gens pour nous aider quand
on est quand on est vieux et est en fait
qu est-ce que c'est ça l'éducation le
feu d'un pardon raison pour qu'on fait
mais justement c'est là où je l'économie
revient parce que tout ça tout ça tout
ça c'est quoi tout ça c'est les dépenses
publiques l'éducation le système de
retraite le la scolarisation des femmes
les
la contraception bonne koussa ancien
comme en russie ça fait baisser le taux
de natalité non oui mais parce que les
femmes étaient déjà évoqué sa pas fait
baisser le taux d' indications des
femmes ce qui assez que
parce que les pouvoirs c'est que les la
crise 4 des églises des années 90 en
russie c'est catastrophique c'est
augmenter le taux de mortalité etc les
gens à changer leurs habitudes ce qui
veut dire qu'ils étaient déjà il avait
déjà des habitudes de pays développés et
à une transition ça veut dire que ça
joue sur plusieurs générations donc si
on veut aujourd'hui réguler la
démographie africaine puisque c'est
encore le continent qui se développe le
plus d'un point de vue démographique il
faut investir en masse sur l'éducation
sur la santé sur les retraites dont
créer des états sociaux et ça c'est
totalement contradictoire avec la
logique du à bannir absolument pas la
logique bakiev est certain c'est parce
qu'il fait en ce moment nous alors en
fait en fait en partie oui parce que
concrètement les taux d'éducation en
afrique augmente beaucoup moi j'ai des
étudiants africains qui sont d'un niveau
qui sont le meilleur en meilleur c'est
pas uniquement fonction qui sont qui
sont très beaux et c'est pas uniquement
les classes et
oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'il y avait pas
d'un système éducatif il ya trente ans
il y avait rien mais aujourd'hui
commence à voir des universités
commencent à avoir un système éducatif
secondaire et on remarque d'ailleurs
qu'il commence à avoir une transition
démographique en afrique on n'est plus
du tout sur les taux de croissance alors
et ça reste encore dans certains pays
mais je vous dis le maghreb on est à
moins de deux enfants par femme
aujourd'hui
dans certains pays d'afrique de l'ouest
on est largement avancé dans la
transition démographique il reste
évidemment des pays dans lesquels cette
provision de leur fille capable alors on
commence et on prend des pays avec un
taux de on a aussi un taux de croissance
économique est très fort en afrique
aussi le problème pour l'afrique c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le taux de croissance il
vient essentiellement du capital privé
international c'est-à-dire il vient ils
sont pas maîtres de leur propre économie
c'est des intentionnistes en esclavage
économique
c'est pas tout à fait un esclavage
économique un peu partout riverains
c'est fin c'est quoi
les francs cfa non mais ça c'est con
quoi moi j'ai pas d'avis tranché sur
français parce que ça crée donc un
ennemi courageux quelques bises non mais
c'est pas ça c'est que d'abord je c'est
difficile de parler au nom des africains
ensuite on a des pays qui sont sortis du
rang
quand on regarde les pays qui sont
sortis du franc cfa
les pays qui s'en sortir en baroeul
attention il ya des blick sont sortis
des francs cfa qui vont pas forcément
mieux de sauf que ceux qui sont restés 1
concrètement les taux de croissance
économique sont pas supérieurs chez ceux
qui ont sont sortis mois sur une
progression de principe je pense que les
pays doivent être souverain sur la
question monétaire mais concrètement
c'est aux pays africains d'en décider
s'ils veulent rester les plaies ne
peuvent décider
petit gamin qui en a qui ont il y en a
qui sont sortis du franc cfa comme alors
je crois le cameroun est sorti du franc
cfa
voilà c'est pareil il faut réviser mais
j'ai forte la monnaie
unique il faut l'histoire du franc cfa
il ya un arbitre entre deux choses le
franc cfa sur quoi une stabilité
monétaire
mais par contre les pays les pays les
pays africains de la zone franc ont pas
de politique monétaire autonome donc r
il faut il faut faire la balance entre
les deux qu'est ce qui est le mieux
d'avoir une politique monétaire autonome
ou de garder la stabilité financière
voilà les ce problème qui se pose pour
le français a faim il se pose aussi dans
d'autres parties du monde je prends un
exemple l'équateur
l'équateur a choisi l'équateur de corée
h où ils ont choisi quoi la
dollarisation c'est à dire qu'ils ont
supprimé leurs monnaies nationales et là
ils ont ils utilisent le dollar des
etats unis c'est la monnaie nationale en
equateur donc là ça veut dire que en
termes de politiques monétaires ils ont
des marges de manoeuvre est égal à zéro
bon mais pourquoi ils ont fait ça parce
que avec l'instabilité politique qui
avait depuis des dizaines d'années donc
avec des taux d'inflation enfin bon la
stabilité économique politique
bon ça c'est pas beau pour un pour un
pays donc ils ont préféré faire ça
abandonner cette souveraineté monétaire
mais avoir en contrepartie une stabilité
une plus grande stabilité aujourd'hui la
question se pose est-ce qu'on doit
revenir à une monnaie nationale ou
garder ça la presse et aux pays
considérés de faire la balance entre les
deux qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
reprendre les rênes en matière monétaire
et qui sait ce que ça nous fait perdre
de notre côté voilà et là il n'y a pas
de réponse d'ailleurs tu disais que
david était je vais me défendre je te
défonce que îlots terrain alors nous
jugeons qu'il votait un peu en touche
non mais là sur ce genre de questions il
sait pas noir ou blanc c'est pas oui ou
non ces cantines schopenhauer pas mal
il est passionnant et le ces coréens qui
était co correa qui était le président
équatorien qui était un type très à
gauche que t'es pas du tout pro
américain côté je joue bien ce qu'a
voulu oui en partie aussi c'est vrai et
donc pas du tout un pro américain et il
s'est retrouvé il arrivait le dollar
était déjà dans l'économie équatorienne
mais il n'a pas voulu après grande
discussion avec les économistes avec
jean françois breau solitaire il a
refusé de revenir sur la dollarisation
alors il essaie de créer des monnaies
virtuelles pour se donner un peu
d'autonomie mais si les passes il a pas
choisi de revenir au sucre que tu es la
monnaie équatorienne avant la le dollar
c'est parce que il a considéré que les
risques étaient supérieurs aux bénéfices
jeu
c'est pour ça que je préfère botter en
touche parce que ces questions sont
compliquées je trouve que c'est
insatisfaisant je trouve que c'est pas
satisfaisant de considérer que la
politique monétaire doit être déléguée à
une autorité par exemple pour l'afrique
c'est là finalement la banque centrale
européenne puisque le franc cfa il est
en fait un excès sur l'euro qui est la
politique monétaire et la banque
centrale européenne qui elle-même
regarde l'économie allemande ça n'a
aucun sens que le sénégal et sa monnaie
qui soit organisée par la bce ça c'est
clair que c'est pas satisfaisant d'un
point de vue de diriger de vue parce que
la france revient aux français ce que la
france récupère une souveraineté est ce
que on fait quoi on sort de l'europe
exit on fait quoi
attraper patate chaude
mais
on est tous
on est tous très très critique
effectivement la construction européenne
et de la monnaie unique telle qu'elle a
été construit sa 1 re penser que par la
monnaie on allait faire converger
les façons de produire à une façon de
vivre même gamme c'est-à-dire y avait
vraiment quelque chose autour de l'idée
que comme on n'arriverait pas à faire en
premier une convergence politique des
systèmes politiques les institutions
politiques des états sociaux que ça
c'était trop compliqué ans ils vont en
faire une monnaie unique et ça va venir
par l'économie et c'est pas du tout ça
qui est arrivé bien évident c'est une
manière coercitive de le faire donc on
voit les tensions maintenant de plus en
plus forte donc nous déconstruire cette
europe c'est-à-dire cette europe là on
estime qu'elle va pas dans le bon sens
etc il n'est pas question enfin moi je
je je vois je ne suis pas pour autant
pour un repli des nations je pense qu'il
est la question européenne qu'est-ce que
l'idée que quelque chose au niveau de
l'europe se construire dès qu'ils
quittent les institutions européennes
qui sont pertinentes j'en suis convaincu
mais pas celle de l'institution
européenne les institutions européennes
globalement convocation gérer la monnaie
unique et à mettre en place les marchés
donc à mettre en place les a poussé les
peler les politiques de compétitivité
dans tous les secteurs bon je pense que
l'europe les institutions européennes
peuvent faire autre chose
par exemple la question écologique elle
a vocation à être géré au niveau
européen même au niveau plus grand mais
dieu voulant s'essayer avec il ya des
questions qui sont les questions qui
concernent toute l'europe
par contre évidemment l'euro tel qu'il
est
c'est l'épaule il est pas du tout
satisfaisant alors après maintenant est
ce qu'il faut en sortir c'est moi je
dirais moi je suis plutôt effectivement
pour tu tiens toujours regarder ton
boulot vision t'écoute
cd cd
finalement c'est une question qui ce qui
ce
qui
c'est une question politique
fondamentalement c'est à dire la
question n'est pas de savoir ce qu'il
faut faire c'est qu'est-ce qu'il est
envisageable de faire est-ce qu'on peut
raisonnablement continuer à dire il faut
100 g la banque centrale européenne
alors même qu'on sait qu'on a beaucoup
de mal à agir sur la banque centrale
européenne que c'est très compliqué et
c'est donc comment se dit c'est une
stratégie qui est pas voilà c'est une
stratégie qui est perdante on peut avoir
l'idée de sortir de l'euro mais sortir
de l'euro c'est à des effets qui sont
difficilement
de risque de répondre
ça serait une situation totalement
nouvelle il n'y a aucun précédent donc
pour juger c'est un peu un saut dans
l'inconnu donc ce que par exemple si
prace en grèce a refusé de a refusé de
faire ce que lui proposait varoufakis à
l'époque yannis varoufakis son ministre
des finances mais hilare tous et
bienvenue en baisse quand même non ben
oui il a
des présidentiables mais derrière ils
n'ont pas été élu pour sortir de l'euro
parce que les grecs sont très attachés
justement à l'europe et même à l'euro
dans une certaine mesure mais ils ont
été élus pour changer la politique
économique sortir des politiques
d'austérité bon et si prince n'a pas
voulu franchir le pas supplémentaire et
ou de mettre dans la balance si vous
n'acceptez pas ce que nous on veut faire
aussi on sort de l'euro ce qui a conduit
à sa perte mais là c'est vrai que c'est
difficile et c'est difficile moi je
parfois je me dis oui il faudrait
peut-être en sortir puis farah je me
libère et non alors c'est pas
satisfaisant certainement comme réponse
mais c'est éminemment compliqué ce sujet
là et au sein des économistes atterrés
il ya les deux positions et il n'y a pas
de c'est un des sujets sur lesquels n'y
a pas de deux jeunes à m'imiter jour une
boîte à retourner la bande à david vous
êtes tous universitaires et tous
fonctionnaires quittent vous trois a
déjà créé une boîte
non non non non après avoir des
associations
l'ours à flers et si des choses comme ça
ça vous pas un peu long c'est ce que
c'est parce qu'en passant
par les jouets laquelle il a cassé la
neige que ben l'oncle soul bol pour la
prochaine audience toujours je vois tu
veux revenir ça c'est pas super g s'est
construit on serait moins efficace où on
serait parce que c'est le monde de
l'entreprise on parle de l'entreprise
comme alors qu'on n'est pas
là alors je voulais prendre des balles
maintenant on n'est pas allé non mais
moi je répondrai simplement à ça c est
ce que pour soigner un cancer seulement
une personne qui a déjà eu le cancer
peut le faire pour pour sortir de la
crise de 33 aux états unis mettent un
kennedy à la tête de la régulation des
marchés financiers
on est toujours dans les questions de
rapport de force dont je parlais tout à
l'heure mais pas forcément on est
forcément les briques ou les liens mais
d'accord on n'a pas mis un kennedy dans
les marchés financiers il y avait le
taire le nom mais le père kennedy avait
un rôle je sais plus quel était son
poste exactement mais il a eu un rôle
dans les années 30
merci
donc il faut un loup pour réguler les
loups non
non
non parce que ça c'est l'argument
typique des élites c'est de dire c'est
que les élites et 15 et 12 euros je sais
pas belle alors que ton connaît d élite
2 o mais moi personnellement non c'est
pas mon milieu pas le milieu dans lequel
je perds et où j'évolue mais les et les
îles quand je parle des élites
économiques
c'est les grands chefs d'entreprise ce
et c'est toutes ces personnes qui ont
dont les décisions ont un impact sur des
milliers ou des millions de gens donc
voilà c'est pas effectivement le petit
artisan du coin mais ce sont les grandes
les grandes firmes multinationales et
représentants de grandes firmes
multinationales
il ya d'essayer les banquiers les élites
politiques etc qui alors je prendrai
dire qu' un complot je n'ai pas du tout
ça mais qui ont des intérêts communs et
qui arrive beaucoup plus facile et
intéressant et bien les intérêts le oui
puisqu'il leur bénéficie leur profil on
alignera une mignonne non mais c'est à
dire le système tel qu'il est c'est à
dire dans sa propre logique il ya quand
même une certaine logique en tant que
système mal tel qu'il est c'est à dire
que sous la bannière la manière dont on
crée effectivement de la richesse et
comment elle est répartie la question du
pouvoir parce qu'effectivement la
richesse et le pouvoir voilà sont les
deux vont ensemble
ce sont des systèmes pacifique institué
d'accord qui permettent à ces gens là de
rester dans une position de pouvoir voir
et mick et de pouvoir politique et le
pouvoir médiatique les trois ans et
ensemble donc quand il était quand ils
ont des intérêts communs sais pas qui
s'appelle et ils mangent ensemble et se
disent avec un échiquier ils font ça
peut-être un peu mais il faut pas
référence à coller bildenberg les
conneries comme ça non mais yaya diallo
compte des cercles comme ça on sait tous
que c'est ça oui voilà on sait qu'il ya
des shows mais moi je ne suis pas
spécialiste de j'ai pas fait de la
sociologie des élites donc je vais pas
être très précise donc qui fait quoi qui
mangent avec qui et
qui fait autre chose
exactement je suis pas du tout la norme
est visible il suffit et 7 non mais bien
sûr mais c'est pas simplement s'inquiète
important ce qui est important c'est
comme ils savent qu'ils ont des intérêts
comment ils se reconnaissent il suffit
pas grand chose pour comprendre que
effectivement dans une position de
pouvoir si je vois quelqu'un d'autre qui
a un autre pouvoir important aussi
important que le mien j'ai un intérêt
avec lui de maintenir le système pour
rester dans une position de pouvoir au
détriment de la terre de l'écologie ça
mais c'est vrai qu'on est on est enfin
moi je crois qu'on est dans une période
quand même assez inouï historiquement
c'est parce qu'on a on a les questions
qui sont posées maintenant à un niveau
tel que
[Musique]
fécond la révolution
arrivé là et comment comment vous mais
moi je suis plutôt c'est surtout jamais
quand ça s'arrête
là du 4 août on en est où
des privilèges qui ont été abolies ça
c'est sûr et sans jamais été rétabli
totalement mais pour revenir sur fin et
je pense qu'il ya aussi il ya des
intérêts communs il ya une sociologie
des élites je suis entièrement d'accord
mais il ya aussi une idéologie une
vision du monde en commun le c'est pour
moi c'est nous ou universitaire on est
surtout là pour questionner l'idéologie
et la vision du monde on n'est pas des
acteurs je dire voilà on n'est pas une
idée très riche ni des banquiers
centraux ni 17 entreprises c'est pas
notre rôle notre rôle c'est d'essayer de
de décortiquer les analyses qui sont
faites les analyses théoriques parce que
ces types là ils ont quand même ils ont
bonne conscience ils sont fils autres
ans qu'ils ont besoin ils ont besoin de
croire non sont pas philanthropes mais
ils ont besoin de croire que ce qu'ils
font n'est pas contradictoire avec
l'intérêt général d'où ce que eric
disait à propos de l'idéologie dû marché
la main invisible à la main invisible
c'est magnifique mois en poursuivant mon
intérêt personnel égoïste je contribue à
l'intérêt collectif donc allons-y soyons
égoïste finalement 7,7 cette logique là
les renforce dans leur idée que ils ont
parfaitement le droit de mener leurs
propres politiques de se défendre leurs
propres intérêts il ya des lobbyistes
mais il ya aussi des gens qui disent aux
lobbyistes et de lobbies qui sont eux
mêmes convaincus que c'est la seule
manière d'avoir une démocratie c'est à
dire concrètement que les legends
confrontent leurs l'ordre leur opinion
confrontent leurs intérêts et de ceux là
émergera l'intérêt collectif et je pense
que nous rené mongrain la démocratie
lomé en démocratie la démocratie c'est
là c'est la manière dont on organise la
confrontation d'intérêt c'est sait rien
d'autre que ça est ce que tu te trouve
qu'on arrive à confronter quelque chose
lancement bah oui oui que logiquement ou
confronte du vent ben non socialement
parlant confronte du vent non il ya des
décisions qui sont prises les décisions
qui sont prises par exemple macron il a
expliqué que ces décisions de plus taxer
le capital ou de moins taxer le capital
ça sert à attirer les investisseurs pour
relancer l'emploi donc il va réussir moi
j'ai vu une tribune dans le monde d'hier
ou un truc comme ça des gens qui disent
nous on est des macros nist de gauche et
on dit que ce que faire macron c'est
aller vers l'égalité et évidemment on va
vivre quand on voit concrètement les
politiques qui mènent et qu'on voit le
la baisse un label ou les revenus des
retraités actuellement enfin la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat des français la
hausse de fait des inégalités depuis que
ces politiques seront menées on peut
dire non on va pas vers l'égalité avec
ça mais le problème c'est que eux ils
ont une théorie qui leur dit que si et
ils ont des idiots suffisamment
convaincu pour aller voter en tout cas
eux mêmes déjà convaincu après est-ce
qu'ils sont convaincants moi je trouve
cette tribune du monde je vous renvoie
ce qu'ils peuvent retrouver je me
souviens plus de son titre mais elle est
parue voilà hier je crois où les mecs
ils disent voilà sans aucun complexe
macron sais c'est la gauche macron est
un progressiste je crois que c'est à peu
près ça le type de leur tribune bon
voilà ce que veut dire c'est que le
débat idéologique il est très important
on peut pas juste
les gens qui font les gens qui sont
responsabilité il faut au minimum que
hills et pour certains d'entre eux en
tout cas au moins que ce soit un minimum
convaincu que ce qu'ils font ça sert à
ça sert les autres ça pas que eux mêmes
mais aussi et surtout il faut qu'il y
ait des gens qui soient convaincus que
ceux qui font que ce que ces personnes
font les sert l'intérêt général et donc
on a des théories qui vont expliquer que
wibree le libre-marché la halle à
l'organisation ou la la la la baisse de
la peau sur les sociétés de l'impôt sur
les sociétés la baisse de l'impôt sur le
capital la baisse de l' isf tout ça il
faut qu'ils aient des gens qui
théorisent le fait que ça va apporter
effectivement du capital la croissance
et la guerre c'est bien bas il ya des
gens qui disent ah bien sûr on n'a
jamais fait la guerre en dix ans la
guerre c'est mal
c'est pas mais en fait c'est pas c'est
pas la guerre économique d'ailleurs ils
le disent qu'ils disent pas la guerre
économique qui disent une saine
concurrence et la saine concurrence et
des règles de concurrence organisée et
les mêmes pour tous mais déjà ça c'est
problématique alors parlons de la guerre
économique qui a théorisé la guerre
économique en france
il ya eu il ya eu des rapports les
rapports de yonou que d'intelligence
économique a été alors le rapport marche
mais alors moi je ne suis pas
spécialiste de sa meilleure semble de
rapports qui ont été faits dans les
années 90 sur est ce qu'un chômeur un
chômeur issue de la guerre économique
parce que c'est une guerre est ce qu'un
chômeur de la guerre économique coûte
plus cher et donc plus débilitants pour
l'etac qu'un réellement
on sait qu'il faudra les
choses en question parce que les états
s'étant est ce qu'elle est en train de
se faire une guerre économique pour
aller tuer des gens
alors à moyen terme par ce phénomène là
mais comme ses plus beaux keable dans
les médias et que ça permet de se
rapporter un petit peu de sous dans les
poches est-ce qu'on en est arrivé à ce
degré d'agressivité entre états on jase
moi j'irai quoi jusqu'à la
fosse
il faut se mondialisation on dit pas
long feu la guerre économique ont dit on
va mener des politiques de compétitivité
ça veut dire exactement la même chose ce
qu'a fait l'allemagne dans les années 90
ce qu'a fait l'allemagne quand elle a
baissé ses salaires d'orwell un club
mais l'allemagne en 90 elle fait une
compression salariale alors elle
organise ça pour financer la
réunification
oui en gros les institutions allemandes
font que les salaires les salariés les
salles les salaires en tant que vrai
jument qui n'augmente quasiment pas
après la réunification en allemagne et
du coup ça fait une augmentation très
forte de la compétitivité allemande
cette compétitivité qui est le porte
préjudice elles portent préjudice aux
partenaires commerciaux de l'allemagne
que sont les pays européens les premiers
partenaires commerciaux et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe on va voir que
tout tout tout l'industrie européenne
tous les investissements industriels
vont se focaliser en allemagne là où on
a les infrastructures les salaires qui
ce qui augmente peu les infractions les
meilleurs et donc c'est évidemment ça se
fait au détriment de leurs partenaires
économiques et alors c'est toute
l'ambiguïté du projet européen qui nous
dit on va essayer de créer de la
solidarité en europe mais pour ça on va
unifier l'économie et le marché sauf que
le marché dans sa nature même il crée
divergences il polarise c'est à dire que
concrètement les plus forts et gagnent
davantage les plus fermes perdre et on a
ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire
l'effondrement de l'europe du sud à
partir à partir de 2010 2000 2011 et ça
pour par rapport à ça il faut faut
essayer de rien intégré des mécanismes
de solidarité mais quand tout le monde
se déteste qu'est ce qu'on a on a des
crises des migrants qui invite les états
sont incapables de gérer surtout juger
après eric europe elle éclate les kappa
la pelouse vient tous par balles et oui
je vais sortir ma boule de cristal
l'économiste il est souvent il est très
fort pour expliquer ce qui s'est passé
et penser du
moins pour prédire l'avenir parce que
évidemment par définition est incertain
et voilà mais
moi ce que moi je peux pas prédire si
l'europe a explosé dans six mois dans un
an dans 10 ans ou s'il va pas exploser
va y avoir un rebond il peut y avoir un
événement particulier à un moment qui
change complètement la donne j'en sais
rien ça peut être un événement
climatique majeur qui du coup fait
prendre conscience à tout le monde que
le vrai problème c'est ça et on s'y met
ça peut être une guerre malheureusement
ça peut être enfin on peut l'imaginer on
peut imaginer plein de choses bon
moi ce que je voudrais quand même
ajouter par rapport à ce que ce qu'on
dit mireille et david s'est on vit quand
même dans un monde orwellien
moi j'invite les gens à relire ou s'ils
n'ont pas lu le 1984 de george orwell
ferme des animaux spa mais aussi la
ferme des animaux est très bien aussi
mais s'il faut ce qu'ils ont lu s'il se
rappelle il y avait il ya le ministère
de la vérité et sur le fronton du
ministère de la vérité vous aviez la
guerre c'est la paix
le l'ignorance c'est la force et la
liberté c'est l'esclavagé bon ben en
europe au sein de l'union européenne
avec cette construction très néo
libérale et bien on à la guerre
économique c'est la paix c'est ce qu'on
nous vend on nous vend c'est que la
compétition de tous contre tous qui va
créer la paix en europe c'est une
absurdité et de la même façon qu'on nous
dit et bien l'égoïsme c'est la
solidarité voilà comme on disait tout à
l'heure chacun chacun pour soi et ça va
bénéficier à tous voilà mais il ya
tellement d'exemples dans les des choses
plus concrètes aujourd'hui on parle plus
licenciement on parle de plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi une entreprise
vire 3000 personnes en dise un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi
flexisécurité monde et il ya tout un tas
de choses rires non mais il ya les mots
sont toujours très importants les uns
sont certes ils sont soumis à un jury et
musées il ya ça aussi bien sûr camus et
ses influences quand même à minima je
connais pas tous en économie mais
combien tu gagnes combien je gagne par
mois aujourd'hui moi je gagne 3200 euros
après près de vingt ans d'ancienneté
c'est bon tu peux continuer c'est
suffisant ou c'est trop ou si tu connais
qui a vu entre 1200 euros j'achète bon
et du coup je ne sais plus ce que
j'étais en train de dire qu'il fait
exprès ouais ouais je me doute bien en
rouelles wii dont nouvelle routine à
nouveau mais dont on est dans cet
univers là quand macron maquereau et le
spécialiste pour brouiller les pistes le
en même temps c'est magique ce truc là
parce que il en il envoie des signaux
contradictoires dans tous les sens il
utilise des termes pour faire dire le
contraire et puis ses ministres ils vont
gaiement quand vous avez marlène
schiappa qui cite karl marx pour
justifier les justifier la politique
actuelle de de macron fait on croit
rêver mais ça c'est moi je pensais c'est
volontaire comme stratégie parce que
quand vous fait perdre les repères à
tout le monde eh bien vous essayez de
vous raccrocher à ce que vous pouvez et
vous raccrocher à quoi ou premier qui a
l'air de vous dire un truc un peu près
sens et qui a le sourire ultra bright
qui est jeune qui a l'air sympa et
et qui vous dit qu'il a un projet à tous
un nouveau gourou économique qui nous
annonce au sein du monde oui aussi non
mais c'est ça après quand on perd quand
on quand on perd l'ouïe l'ailé des
repères des repères économiques des
repères politiques
c'est toujours la même chose c'est cette
stratégie du choc cette stratégie elle a
été faite aussi dans les pays colonisés
le colonialisme ont cédé quoi dès qu'on
arrivait ont supprimé quoi parlait la
langue les modes vestimentaires
etc etc donc vous supprimez tout ce qui
fonde l'identité d'une d'un pays vous
fragiliser les gens et ils n'ont plus
qu'à se raccrocher à quoi ce que
proposait colonisateur ben là c'est un
peu c'est un peu de là dans un autre
domaine mais c'est un peu la même chose
on et puis bon le jeu des médias
dominants qui on sait il ya une
concentration tél là c'est pareil vous
avez des médias nous aux économistes
atterrés on peut démontrer par a plus b
scientifiquement qu'il ya des choses qui
sont fausses économiquement etc mais
vous avez toujours les mêmes et même au
zoo sur les plateaux télé qui ânonnent à
répétition les mêmes les mêmes si les
psys louable nous on en est une préférée
moi j'en ai oui oui mais moi je veux
enfin moi je n'aime que j'aime beaucoup
c'est agnès verdier-molinié la fondation
ifrap alors là non le slogan c est à
kaka donc est vrai n'importe quoi peut
le décliner sous n'importe quelle force
et ça aussi c'est que vous deviez agnès
verdier molinié
donc c'est une fondation un think tank
financé par le patronat donc ok la voix
de son maître mais le problème c'est que
quand vous répéter une est une ineptie
en boucle sur tous les plateaux télé au
bout d'un moment ça devienne vérité
voilà c'est ça le problème surtout quand
les journalistes sont aussi tu es quand
les italiens c'est aussi tes goûts tout
le monde tout ce petit monde pour noront
effectivement quand vous entendez intel
a dit ça et intel a dit s'installer
c'est la même chose et vous dit
peut-être que c'est vrai si vous
connaissez rien en économie c'est bien
sinon oui donc c'est vrai qu'on est bien
ici parce qu'on a un peu la parole libre
moi je voudrais revenir sur quelque
chose quand tu dis l'état sait qu'un
casque dit en la personne je dirais je
me rappelais sans nom là maintenant mais
en fait le néolibéralisme c'est quelque
chose d'assez d'assez particulier parce
qu'on le sait pas le moins d'état au
final c'est à dire ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on a vu vraiment dans l'histoire du
néolibéralisme c'est plutôt un état dont
l'agenda a changé et une transformation
importante de l'état qui fait qui fait
d'ailleurs le lien vers ce que disait
david tout à l'heure c'est dire qu'en
fait toutes ces politiques là ce qu'on
appelle le néolibéralisme la
financiarisation
de la déréglementation des marchés
financiers la déréglementation du
secteur bancaire etc ça a été porté par
les états à la recherche de leur propre
puissance faut bien se rappeler que
nixon 71 la fin dortmund c'est parce que
je vais financer la guerre au vietnam
donc c'est les etam en fait ils sont
complètement parties prenantes ils sont
même pas partie prenante ils sont nés
aux libéraux c'est à dire qu'il se
transforme pour accompagner le
capitalisme dans sa mue néolibérale et
cette transformation elle passe par une
fragilisation de la démocratie
représentative c'est à dire que les
états se transforment ils deviennent pas
du tact orio pour autant on en est pas
encore alors je sais pas si ça sera la
suite j'en sais rien mais ils sont dans
une forme qui est beaucoup plus centré
sur l'exécutif et les parlements tous
les parlements européens les parlements
aux états unis etc on voit que le
pouvoir des parlements de moins en moins
important les exécutifs près le prennent
le pas avec l'idée convard et lure un
représentant pour cinq ans c'est le cas
c'est ce que dit macron 7 est rejeté et
eugene légitimité qui est au dessus de
la société civile et pendant 5 ans je
fais ce que je veux parce que je suis au
dessus de la société civile je suis au
dessus des pouvoirs intermédiaire je
n'ai plus de je n'ai pas de raison de me
plier à discuter avec tel ou tel
syndicat tel ou tel autre
même le parlement donc il ya vraiment
une forme en fait d'une démocratie
représentative qui s'est énormément
affaibli qui permet que l'état devienne
un état finalement un état fort très
coercitif quand tu disais par rapport à
1984 je trouve que c'est très très bien
de contrôle
et d'individualisation c'est à dire on
dit chacun doit agir là où il est
ce sont aux formes et faire son auto
entreprise être tout seul et se donner
les moyens de s'en sortir tout seul et
ensuite l'état va contrôler tout ça pour
éviter que ça explose donc on est dans
une situation avec une montée en fait de
la coercition du contrôle alors même
qu'on n'arrête pas de nous dire qu'on
est dans une société d'autant plus
libérée on va libérer le marché du
travail on valide on va défaire voilà
donc comme prévu en crédit évidemment
cette rémunération est une crime
bureaucratie néolibérale je renvoie à ce
que les le livre de david graber
bureaucratie je renvoie aussi à la
privatisation de l'aéroport à tous les
systèmes de partenariat public privé qui
sont des systèmes avec des contrats de
l'île de 2000 pages extrêmement complexe
et c'est ça qu'on fait concrètement la
privatisation des profits s'est les
concessions autoroutières c'est une
perpétuelle négociations commerciales de
oui mais c'est aussi une organisation
bureaucratique faire concrètement c'est
que c'est pas les petites pme qu'on
utilisait ses vingt six et les grands
groupes du btp qui vont qui vont
négocier des contrats avec l'état dans
lequel eux-mêmes vont être en position
de force parce que finalement bas l'état
il donne des gages de l'état néolibéral
c'est pas l'état au service des citoyens
mais qui ont fait commander des marchés
avant jeu juste qu'on était radicalise
économiquement a rougi bien mais juste
ce effectivement tu as raison quand je
disais agnès verdier-molinié de façon un
peu exagérée elle c'est une ultra
libérale donc ultra libérale c'est pas
d'état au moins d'étapes aussi lors le
néolibéralisme en fait ça renvoie la
doctrine allemand de l'ordo libéralisme
ou là l'état ait pu un acteur au sein de
l'économie voire un acteur moteur comme
c'était le cas pour
ce que prônée par exemple keynes avec la
création de l'état providence qui s'est
mis en place d'après la seconde guerre
mondiale là l'état néolibéral l'état
ordolibérale lui celle arbitres il est
là pour fixer des règles du jeu qui
favorise le bon fonctionnement du marché
donc c'est un état au service du marché
copains et du coup pas au service de
l'intérêt général et du bien commun fait
que vous pour l'aider radicaliser
économiquement pendant ces gens là alors
je rebondis sur la perche kim étendu sur
la des règles claires qui sont carrément
des châles mauvais parce que j'ai le
droit de faire mon auto promo
effectivement j'en parle dans un petit
ralentir un très bon ouvrage que
j'écrive indices et les pieds pierre
bellemare te regarde voilà oui du jour
pierre qui s'appelle justement
l'intégrisme économique et dans lequel
je j'abordais je décrivais l'analyse
économique dominante sous l'angle d'un
athée ça fonctionne comme un intégrisme
religieux ont parlé du marché c'est le
dieu le dieu marché on serait vert au
marché d'ailleurs il ya qu à voir on
entend quand on entend certains
journalistes économiques parler les
marchés ont dit que les marchés et non
des noues nombre tout ce qu'on peut
trouver sur les médias
serbes françois lenglet il est très bien
oui dans ce cadre là il est très bien
il ya pire
ah oui dominique seux voilà bon là vous
avez le catéchisme effectivement qui est
répétée poutre avec rien des apôtres il
ya tout ce que l'on veut on peut hein
j'ai développé ça dans le livre si ça
intéresse certains ou certaines et la
déradicalisation donc c'est arrivé c'est
très difficile parce que de la même
façon que les intégristes religieux pour
leur faire revenir dans le monde réel
c'est ça les intégristes économique pour
moi doug ils sont sortis du monde réel
ils n'arrêtent pas de nous vendre des
trucs dont on le voit depuis quarante
ans que ça produit les effets inverses
de ceux qui nous vendent et comme tout
intégristes et ça fait 40 ans que les
gens un groupe sain oui médoc
l'intégriste le quand quand la réalité
montre que la théorie à tort eh bien ils
vont vous dire c'est la réalité qui se
trompent alors j'ai une question à vous
ça fait 40 ans que pour parler
trivialement oms l'a fait m
ma question formulée d'une façon light
est ce que il n'ya pas un problème
cognitif au niveau de la population pour
comprendre les théories économiques ou
est-ce que leur système nerveux central
n'arrivent plus à s'en tire qui cela tu
comprends mais n'avait pas ce qu'on agit
de plus en plus on agit sur quoi ontario
parce qu'ils sont trop courts non parce
qu'on agit beaucoup plus sur les
émotions dans cette société de comptes
de communication et ça on agit beaucoup
plus sur les émotions à dire sur le
cerveau reptilien que sur la réflexion
sur l'intelligence des gens si c'est un
peu con quand même non mais oui
vas-y vas-y mais je pense que
ce que ce qui fait l'aliénation parce
qu'on va tu dis ce qui pour quoi elles
comprennent pas et sait c'est que
l'économie est présenté comme un
discours de science et la science et
voilà c'est à dire la science on va pas
questionner tv voilà que la terre est
ronde donc il ya une loi de la
gravitation donc ça c'est ce que yang
oui mais d'ailleurs un vrai scientifique
en quelqu'un comme compal avec un vrai
scientifique il dit de toutes les façons
il faut toujours doute émane de ce qui a
été établi et le doute fait partie de la
science or là en fait on a on a
on a
on a en fait une conception de
l'économie qui se présente avec les
figures de la science avec en plus une
technicité relativement élevé ce qui
fait que souvent quand on se présente
comme économiste ou conduites ont fait
de l'économie s'est complexifiée dessin
je comprends rien et c'est donc les gens
effectivement c'est entre le discours de
l'économie qui dit qu'il faut faire si
qu'il faut faire ça et que si on
licencie c'est normal c'est pourquoi
être prise plus tard et si tu dois
travailler plus c'est parce qu'ils sont
encore plus riche plus tard me voilà en
fait c'est ce discours technique empêche
les gens ont pensé ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que on démystifie sur les courtes
et ceux des cours techniques c'est d'une
certaine manière critique et l'économie
en tant que ce que parole scientifique
mois on a faim de mon point de vue c'est
une des manières justement de de
permettre aux gens de tout un chacun 200
paires de sang parle pas des enjeux
économiques et politiques justement pour
les mettre ensemble
alors juste moi je pense aussi que les
gens sont les gens sont pas totalement
dupe concrètement quand on demande aux
gens s'ils sont protectionnistes malgré
tous les discours sur la mondialisation
heureuse sur libre échange sur ont
regardé grâce au commerce des peuples
vont arrêter de se faire la guerre et
bien malgré ça quand on demande aux gens
est ce que vous êtes favorable des
barrières douanières pour pas protéger
vos emplois du dumping chinois les gens
ils sont 87% trompe c'est pour ça qu'au
bout de rue c'est pour 500 kits n'ont
pas non plus dire que les trop
annexionnistes c'est alors moi moi je
pense alors on pourrait discuter de ça
mais je ne pense pas que trump sont un
vrai protectionnistes bon augure et
c'est autre chose c'est des nazis mais
concrètement non oui le sol et les gens
non mais les jambes ne contenait en fait
en france le légendaire grille les gens
ne croient pas les gens ne croient pas
aux bienfaits du libéralisme économique
en particulier bien sûr qu'ils sont pour
les droits de vote bien sûr qu'ils sont
pour les libertés individuelles
plus plus plus que ce qu'on croit même
parfois y compris même dans l'accueil
des migrants mais par contre au niveau
économique ils sont pas dupes du
néolibéralisme et ils sont pas en tout
cas en france entre ils sont pas ils
sont pas dupe sur le fait que
il n'y a pas de libre contrats sur le
marché du travail les employeurs gentil
qui vont négocier gentiment avec les
employés ils savent bien que c'est des
rapports de force sur le marché du
travail ils savent bien que
le sont équipés pour pouvoir les
entendre le problème c'est pas ça le
problème c'est qu'on leur permet pas de
2,2 compte enfin non pas seulement de
comprendre ils le comprennent et me le
permet pas de trouver des débouchés
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui arrive
pour dire qui veut remettre en cause ces
règles là et quelque part il n'est pas
crédible parce que on est dans un carcan
à la fois alors moi je pense qu'il ya un
carcan européen c'est à dire que revenir
sur la libéralisation du dd service
public revenir sur les nationalisations
refaire du de l'état qui régule le
marché alors qu'on a des traités qui
disent linverse c'est très compliqué et
et d'où le désarroi des électeurs
concrètement ils n'ont pas voté de
macron par conviction par enchantement
le le nombre de d'électeurs a été
d'ailleurs faible on avait un taux
d'abstention extrêmement élevé à la
dernière élection présidentielle encore
plus élevés aux législatives
et en fin de compte ce qui était pro
marché il y avait ma kron il y avait
fillon mais est encore fillon il s'était
pas que ça
et les autres il n'est pas vraiment pro
marché en fait donc donc le rapport de
forces est pas du tout les gens sont pas
un coût convaincu en dix ans les les
économistes et des scientifiques qu'ils
ont raison
prosternons nous devant la loi et que
celle de la soumission consentie
soumis justement ils sont ils sont en
quête d'un débouché politique sous
n'existe pas
piocher du côté de ses élites dont on
parlait elle elles sont dans quelque
chose que la bo ici appelé la servitude
volontaire recherche d'une servitude
volontaire
il ya les gagnants qui ont pas envie de
changer de système et français où les
politiques immelt non je suis pas aussi
dur que contre les français - non les
politiques sont très mauvais comme on
disait il ya des classes sociales et il
ya des gens qui ont des intérêts
différents différents et savons peu
voûté
mais oui mais s'ils vont pas voter c'est
que aussi justement la manière dont
s'organise les élections président pour
de la présidentielle où finalement tout
découle de la présidentielle dans
lesquelles 1 personne médiatique et ses
produits évidemment un électorat
alors cet électorat il n'est pas c'est
un moment particulier ensuite les gens
qui ont voté ont des positions qui
peuvent changer dans les cinq ans
auxerre c'est bien plus complexe que ça
mais comme l'orientation politique de
cinq ans et produite par ce moment des
élections présidentielles avec toutes
ces toutes ses
limites et encore je suis gentil quand
j'ai des limites c'est à dire ce
spectacle de personnes qui se confronte
deux sont des plateaux télé avec des
petites phrases et c'est évidemment ce
après sa
réjection produire une construction
d'une alternative c'est à dire que c'est
pas à ce moment là que se construit
chez les citoyens une pensée de
l'alternative de comment on peut réagir
comment on peut par contre moi je
voudrais terminer là dessus et après je
sais que je crois qu'il ya justement une
polarisation entre ce qu'on voit au
niveau
des élites politiques des élections
présidentielles législatives et c est ce
qui se passe à mon avis sur le
territoire et je crois qu'on constate
tous quand on est interrogé en tant
qu'universitaire bon moi je m'occupe de
tout ce que l'économie sociale et
solidaire ou qu'on voit beaucoup sur le
terrain pour les pratiques etc on voit
un foisonnement depuis une dizaine
d'années je pense que 2008 et la bascule
un foisonnement d'initiatives de
citoyenne de toutes sortes avec des
choses qui sont plus ou moins
intéressantes que ce soit
les questions des monnaies locales
question des circuits courts des amap
ddd
supermarché coopératifs ont fait ça mais
aussi des cafés citoyens des espaces
aussi que c'est pas un filet social
réinventer et est-ce que c'est pas une
façon de ralentir un effondrement toutes
ces nouvelles initiatives juste quand je
suis en arrière et je discute avec
nouvelle et j'arrive tout de suite avec
toi d'aller de t'inquiète pas tu vas
avoir la parole vas-y mireille france
non tout laisse pas faire tourner leurs
attentes je crois pas je pense que c'est
tout à fait nécessaire c'est à dire que
ça s'annonce bien défendre on ne peut
pas non mais oui parce qu'en fait tout
ça ce sont des graines qui sont sommés
et qui peut-être germeront alors
évidemment on peut pas comme on dit on
ne peut pas savoir ce qui va arriver
dans l'avenir bien bien sûr l'avenir
n'est pas écrit là dans le présent il
est à construire
mais
ça s'il ya un effondrement ça rendra
l'effondrement moins douloureux parce
que ici et là il y aura des choses qui
auront été déjà expérimenté reconstruite
et c'est donc ça on peut pas dire il
faut rien faire pour aller le plus vite
ce revers l'effondrement
ce serait à mon avis non seulement à ses
cibles en plus ça voudrait dire que
chacun la wii les attend dans son coin
l'effondrement à venir en se demandant
si c'est lui qui va passer en premier ou
pas donc c'est juste pas possible donc
heureusement qu'il ya de l'optimisme moi
je pense qu'il faut être comme des
gramsci il faut être pessimisme dans la
dans l'ain dans l'analyse et optimiste
en action et je pense qu'il y à beaucoup
de choses qui se passent sur le
territoire moi je suis quand même
toujours assez étonné de voir que d'ici
et là énormément de choses se passent
qui sont quand même posé de manière en
opposition radicale avec le capitalisme
avec les tendances actuelles c'est à
dire ils vont c'est pas juste on fait du
social et on va aider le voisin c'est
qu'on a des fonctions dédiées à d'autres
de l'aude bah oui je pense absolument je
pense que symboliquement c'était je
pense que c'est une brèche
révolutionnaire pour moi notre dame des
landes donc on peut discuter de ce
qu'ils y font etc il ya plein de
discussion à voir mais je pense que
c'est ce genre d'initiative qui vont
jusqu'à contester la radicalité de ce
qui se fait en agriculture est
intéressante à voir alors évidemment
c'est pas de notre on va pas avoir d
notre dame des landes partout c'est pas
la question c'est que ça questionne
symboliquement le capitalisme david non
compris vingt six et je vais revenir
rebondir sur sur sur le discours
médiatique parce que concrètement à quoi
il sert le discours aux médias fiche du
patio qui sert vraiment à convaincre des
gens il convainc que de ceux qui sont
déjà convaincus qu'ils sont les 20 30 %
des personnes qui gagnent au système
actuel qui sont plutôt heureux voire des
cadres supérieurs du privé les
dirigeants d'entreprise par contre il
produit un découragement je veux dire le
le fait que nous servent toujours la
même sauce à kouakou de christophe
barbier de dominique ce qu'on nous
explique n'y a pas d'alternative que
macron c'est un génie parce que regarder
va réformer l'europe les gens ils sont
pas dupes ils sont pas complètement
idiot n'y crois pas complètement mais
ils sont quand même en one je fais mise
et je pense qu'ils sont plus sains que
beaucoup de gens qui ont beaucoup de
gens qui se considèrent comme des élites
et le souci c'est quoi le souci c'est
que ce découragement il entraîne du coup
il ya un désaveu si un désinvestissement
citoyens il ya plus personne dans les
partis politiques il ya plus personne il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ne votent pas et
quand ils votent ils votent par défaut
au sens vraiment s'intéresser par contre
et je rejoins ce que dit mireille du
coup qu'est ce que kate comment ils vont
organes zeller lors comment ils vont
changer le monde mais ils vont essayer
de changer le monde par des initiatives
locales exactement ce que tu disais mais
moi je suis plus réservé sur le sens des
initiatives locales par exemple assez
réservé sur notre dame des landes parce
que concrètement c'est des gens qui sont
tellement rupture que à la limite ils
sont persuadés d'avoir la vérité eux ils
sont en petit et la main alors non moi
j'ai pas été un bon économiste mais mais
je n'ai jamais la non mais je moi depuis
toute petite charge elle était dans
d'autres dans d'autres réseaux la rangée
on a je suis déçu en danger donc on a eu
vraiment
justement on a énormément de petits on a
les monnaies locales qui s'appelle la
muse on a continué sur notre justicier
sion gc ca même chose même logique on a
des gens qui vont organiser leur petit
pouvoir citoyen alors alternatif mais le
problème c'est que les rapports de force
existe aussi entre ça et moi moi j'ai un
ami qui a fait une thèse sur les
monnaies locales il appelle tous mes
amis j'ai oublié c'est pas toi mon ami
c'était un c'était un type j'entends je
suivais la thèse il ya quelques années
mais petit prenant
non mais c'est en fait si c'est un ami
on en a discuté on a eu des potes mais
bon soit plus voilà mais concrètement
peu importe je n'arrivais avec il avait
arrive avec des idées il arrivait avec
des idées préconçues disait réformer le
capitalisme ne va pouvoir se faire que
par le bas avec des systèmes alternatifs
des petits groupes de personnes qui vont
quand un produit très peu de cash in
oceano s'extraire de la communauté du
capitalisme en organisant ces choses là
est en fait le problème c'est qu'il
s'est aperçu que les associations qui
supportaient ces monnaies locales a été
politisée de la même façon je dire il y
avait des systèmes de rapports de force
qui avaient des systèmes dac apparemment
de skill des ressources collectives et
donc le problème il est que si on
considère que l'alternative au
capitalisme c'est le multiplier des
petites communautés qui vont se décider
en compte en essayant de faire des
contre modèle mais qui reproduisent en
elle-même des systèmes de rapports de
force et les des systèmes d'accaparement
c'est pas la solution et on a aussi des
gens qui sont aussi un peu parfois
fanatisés bon ça on le voit sur internet
on disait personne ne remet en cause que
la terre est ronde à on a aussi des
types qui sont capables de créer des
communautés totalement débile dans
lequel il voit là ils vont dire que non
la terre est plate donc le souci pour
moi il est que le découragement en zone
non pas un tube schallert le
découragement à l'échelle le
découragement à l'échelle nationale en
fait ne crée pas forcément des véritable
alternative solide concrètement
décourager le national à l'échelle
nationale ça veut dire et l'implication
citoyenne à l'échelle nationale ça veut
dire d'oublier ça veut dire multiplier
son nombre de deux petits groupes qui
vont pas s'entendre qui vaut pas s'unir
et qui vont perdre le sens commun et
surtout vont pas sans organiser et qui
vont pas s'organiser bien sûr et donc on
va donner un débouché à on va rire du
localisme on va donner des débouchés on
va faire des inactifs qui parfois sont
des très bonnes initiatives et des
systèmes de monnaies locales qui
fonctionnent très bien on a moi je pense
au film demain dessus puis comment il
s'appelle qui montrait
dion céline dion c'est ça le film demain
qui montrait des initiatives
alternatives et c'est très bien choisir
les gens ils sont ils sont à fond et
puis c'est pas toujours des trucs
complètement idiot c'est des choses qui
peuvent être écolo qui peuvent être
culturel etc le problème c'est que c'est
finalement on renonce à changer le monde
enfin servant on décide de s'adapter au
système tel qu'il est et de l'est c'est
finalement un peu tranquille la remise
en question du capitalisme doit venir
d'en haut je pense qu'on peut pas on
peut pas se passer du haut je pense
qu'il doit venir d'en bas et elle doit
venir d'en haut il faut des personnes
pour concevoir les rapports de force à
l'échelle internationale et ça ça peut
pas se faire dans son village voilà les
la prise de conscience peut se faire à
n'importe quel niveau mais sans actions
à l'échelle nationale et internationale
c'est très compliqué de changer de monde
donc on peut juste y adapter en fait
bien il t'aide rosie
bon évidemment il faut pas être comment
dire
enthousiaste plus que ça de ce qui se
passe tout ce qui se passe sur le
territoire assez limité ce que tu dis
par rapport au fait qu'il ya des prés
carrés qui a des rapports de force qui
se reconstruise qui finalement sont
évidemment toute façon déjà il faut il
faut il faut dire une chose claire c'est
à dire que quel que soit
le modèle est politique on propose il y
a des rapports de force dans tout rhône
alpes politique la société humaine c'est
une société qui s'institue avec des
rapports de force la question c'est
pourquoi ces rapports de force qu'elles
sont l'essence et cetera dont moi ça me
ça me choque pas disons qu'à priori dans
une organisation une coopérative ou une
association qui avec la question des
rapports de forces et savoir comment
elles sont gérées plus ou moins
démocratiquement ça c'est la première
chose après bon c'est compliqué de
rentrer dans le débat en séance à savoir
si on oppose le local du national où
l'international comme tu disais
évidemment ils s'assemblent la pirouette
un intellectuel se dire que les deux
articule
donc je pense que c'est ce que tu veux
dire et je suis d'accord avant la bâche
garia la tête on est d'accord là dessus
c'est à dire coach alouettes ont compté
plus de son talent mais qui alors moi je
pense qu'effectivement qui sont
intéressantes qui peuvent permettre de
construire un rapport de force un petit
peu quelques pas d'accord parce que les
gens peuvent effectivement plus tenir
s'organiser avoir retrouvé du sang sur
leurs actions politiques etc
moi ce que je dis c'est que la la la on
ne peut pas
simplement analysé la question en disant
il faudrait que ça vienne duo où il
faudrait que sa veine du bain ce qui est
important c'est de regarder ce qui ce
qui se dit sur le territoire y aller il
ya des initiatives ces initiatives elles
n'ont pas toujours les mêmes censée
justement si elle n'arrive pas à
s'organiser c'est parce que certains ne
vont pas dans le sens que d'autres c'est
vrai ce qu'on dit qu'on fait un truc
locales et qu'on est dans le social que
ça là même la même signification que des
choses qui sont beaucoup plus radicales
comme lazare est par exemple donc ce que
je sais que je pense qui est important
c'est regarder la signification de ces
différentes initiatives locales et
l'espoir pourrait venir qu'effectivement
des significations convergent à dire que
finalement au final je pense que les
grandes révolutions se font comme ça
c'est vraiment ça s'agrègent parce qu'il
ya quelque chose poursuit sous lundi
alors pas du tout
voilà je pense que quand il ya une
grande révolution banque en 1789 on peut
discuter de ça mais enfin 593
celle qui fait qu'il ya quand même au
renversement de régime et qu'il ya
quelque chose de nouveau qui advient
c'est parce que je finalement pendant
longtemps partout des significations
nouvelles sont apparues et qui ont
encensé terre qui convergent sur quelque
chose de commun là mais moi je crois
qu'une des indh et les questions
révolution dans la plus importante c'est
la remise en question et du
productivisme et de l'extractivisme fait
partir de 1789 d'ailleurs
généraux et le problème des finances
publiques juste avant que ça
les gens ne croyaient pas un peu la
dalle non
oui mais ça c'est ça c'est ça qu'elle
deviendra un outil fédérateur comme elle
ligne ou d'un côté qui crée des pénuries
alimentaires
parce qu'il faut attendre ça c'est à
dire un événement cataclysmique
pour pouvoir basculer sur un système
plus humain
on
aimerait que la révolution la transition
ou le changement se fasse pas de mal et
ce par un effondrement par la barbarie 1
un vrai que ça se fasse par une voie
beaucoup plus démocratique et sociale
on mérite pour ça les side
c'est pas un peu bisounours on aimerait
mais
gratte le nez pourquoi tu grattes le dès
que tu dises et mobiles et grafite à
l'heure c'est la volonté d'optimisme
concrètement si on n'a pas un minimum
d'optimisme bien sûr que bien sûr que la
probabilité que tout s'effondre et que
nous nous on n'est pas au pouvoir mais
on est des universitaires on est déçu
c'est que universitaires économistes et
en plus hétérodoxe et hétérodoxe quelque
part on n'est pas entendu donc c'est
clairement ces cas n'ont pas notre voie
qui va être choisi et la logique du
système c'est de se reproduire à
l'identique ce n'est pas de changer de
voie mais bon pour la postérité ou une
femme ou pour le fait de pouvoir dire
regardez on vous avait dit lundi qu'on a
eu dans le mur ça vaut le coup de parler
d'une voix forte je voulais juste
revenir sur une année gottman ont
effectivement moi je suis un grand
pessimiste mais je considère quand même
que on a une période on est dans une
période où ce qu'on appelle le
néolibéralisme voix 7 sept
états du capitalisme de plus en plus
financiarisé et c'est le fait que ils
fassent évoluer la démocratie vers des
régimes de plus en plus autoritaire de
plus en plus coercitif et ses montres
quoi montre que c'est un système qui est
en bout de course donc le truc nous ce
qu'on essaie de faire modestement c'est
de l'accompagner en douceur pour essayer
de proposer autre chose alors
l'atterrissage va peut-être plus brutale
mais moi je pense que ce système là il
est à bout de souffle et dans tous les
systèmes à bout de souffle qu'est ce qui
se passe quand quand le système va bien
on convainc les gens et les gens sont
convaincus alors ils sont manipulés
parce que le néolibéralisme a pas
bénéficié à la majorité des gens mais
quand ils s'aperçoivent de la suite
c'est le moins que c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire mais quand ils s'aperçoivent
de la supercherie et donc il demande
autre chose on est dans cette période là
depuis 1 pas mal d'années quand même
maintenant il y demande autre chose et
ceux qui n'ont pas intérêt ce que ça
change mais qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
passent de la manipulation douce à des
quelque chose de plus coercitif c'est ce
que l'on voit aujourd'hui derrière
toujours des discours qui disent le
contraire de ce qu'ils font la liberté
etc et puis derrière on met l'état
d'urgence dans la constitution on réduit
les libertés on surveille de plus en
plus etc etc donc c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est un système qui est en
train de se scléroser et qui arrive à
son terme alors à son terme ce sera la
semaine prochaine dans cinq ans dans dix
ans dans 20 ans j'en sais rien mais
ça c'est sûr que c'est c'est pas ça
c'est quelque chose qui va être dépassé
et moi je rejoins et mireille et david
pour dire que d'ailleurs c'est le but
des économistes atterrés d'essayer de
montrer que l'économie c'est autre chose
qu'un truc super compliqué c'est
effectivement quand on dit qu'on est
économiste olala tout le monde a eu ni
d'expérience hyper douloureuse avec
l'économie à un moment ou un autre on
rigole mais mes deux le truc grincer
beaucoup de dents même peut-être mais le
truc c'est que quand on intervient dans
le débat public qu'on est invité à
droite à gauche par des associations ou
autres et bien et qu'on explique parce
que c'est le boulot de l'universitaire
aussi d'aller dans la cité et de
débattre avec les citoyens et quand on
explique de façon un peu claires de
façon abordable pas dans un jargon
technique noyer derrière des des
relations mathématiques tout plus
compliqué les unes que les autres et
bien les gens on s'aperçoit que y
comprennent ils comprennent alors pas
tous évidemment mais ils comprennent les
mécanismes essentiels de l'économie
parce que ce serait parce que c'est des
choses qui les clics un dos tous les
jours je t'explique comment un gars doux
mais quoi de ricardo
quand ils échangent des chèvres avec des
torchons et joue comme ça voilà la
division internationale du travail oui
la division internationale du travail
c'est de dire il faut là il faut il faut
se spécialiser là où on est le plus
performant le plus cher est un chou qui
tombe sur la piste quand même non plus
c'est le drap et le vin c'est le drive a
pris entre l'angleterre et le portugal
pour être exact et donc voilà ça conduit
à ça et alors évidemment la doctrine
actuelle du libre échange est fondé sur
cette vieille théorie là donc c'est
amusant quand on nous dit que nous on a
des idées passéistes
parce qu'on se réfère à par exemple à
kane sous un
mois je suis pas fan day avec un marc
marquez pour pour tout dire et tant
keynésien keynes et hayek ils ont même
s'ils étaient amis personnels ils ont
vis connaissait bien il s'apprécier en
tant que personne mais sur le front de
la théorie ils sont je me sens en
gravant empaillés la joute oratoire vous
l'amener où avec par exemple ce qui
enseigne à hec ou des choses comme ça
on fait les conférences
les gens en face à face les gens
le problème c'est que nous considère
comme des
cachets des dents d'économistes ou des
économies de seconde zone et qui n'ont
pas à s'abaisser à venir débattre avec
nous on a parfois de quelques débats moi
j'ai fait un reza je me souviens
polytechnique place d'un casino son
indic de tango n'ont pas la donne c'est
fait c'est terminé on a passé on a
changé de sujet mais les débats si on
peut en faire devant une audience
parfois il ya des gens qui invite un pro
et anti donc ça arrive mais c'est très
peu fréquents plus débattre contre eux
qui abat ajouté nous
chercher ce débat très bien avec jean
tirole par exemple on tire on s'est
quand même le prix nobel et que quelque
part
j'ai lu son dernier livre là je pense
qu'il ya énormément de choses à dire à
propos de tout comme un mois l'économie
bien commun et puis c'est quand même
celui qui est le plus connu en france
voilà mais bon bien sûr que lui il
n'était pas d'accent il n'a pas envie de
débattre en fait il n'est pas dans une
posture de débats jean tirole il est
dans une posture eux mêmes je suis
l'économie scientifique il a même écrit
au ministère de de l'éducation en 2016
je sais plus pour dire on débute pour
dire qu'il fallait absolument pas créer
une nouvelle section alors c'est un peu
technique mais une section de conseil
national des universités
qui s'appelait économie politique en
grenon voulait se disent au siège de
vente pour permettre le débat est vite
et permet de créer une section
s'appelait économie et société et l'a
interdit ça donc il ay lanciaux en
disant que les économistes qui étaient
qui voulait faire ça était pas des
scientifiques
exactement et ensuite on a le
négationnisme économique de cahutes esi
berbère à toulouse explique que les en
particulier cité économistes atterrés
qui dit ces gens là sont pas des
scientifiques donc évidemment ne sont
pas dans le débat titre qu ils sont donc
parce que le fait qu'il ait pas de débat
qu'il n'arrive pas à se débarrasser de
vous est ce que c'est pour ça que marion
maréchal-le pen a créé sa propre
université
c'est quoi pour moi c'est du n'importe
quoi c'est un projet politique je vois
pas le lien le lien est très simple
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de débat
qui est l'enseignement est très
polarisée c'est à dire soit proulx soit
soit pas pro non mais là merkel et
marion maréchal-le pen comme tu dis
c'est pas une réaction symptomatique de
cette carence d'échangés de débats mais
nos ressources et une ultra libérale
annoncée une libérale elle est sur les
politiques économiques et pourrait très
bien se retrouver dans ce que je pense
que fait matheron macron là l essai de
cooke macro là elle essaie de se
positionner politiquement en essayant de
trouver une place et qu'on parle d'elle
et qu'elle revienne sur le devant de la
scène avec soin par le biais de son
école mais sincèrement le le front
national
du père le pen était ultra libérale
il ya eu un moment plus souverainiste
protectionnistes avec la période
philippot qui s'est fait virer bon
sincèrement ils reviennent aux
fondamentaux pour moi et marion
maréchal-le pen est un peu dense est
dans cette veine la fin rien de rien de
nouveau et rien à voir avec nous en tout
cas c'est qui se fait avec nous qui
disons les textes des libéraux est eux
qui ne lisent pas nos textes donc c'est
un débat à sens unique si on veut
vraiment au débattre il suffit de lire
les livres des économistes hétérodoxes
je pense pas forcément d'ailleurs les
français
james carlès
ou
enfin de très nombreux économistes
hétérodoxes qui en fait tu traînes les
idées des
boxes des libéraux et qui montre que ça
dysfonctionne le problème c'est que dans
le sens inverse il ya pas de celle ci a
concrètement vu que c'est eux qui
tiennent la science les bonnes revues
c'est eux qui déterminent ce qui est
scientifique et donc il ne débattent pas
et ne disent pas d'autres de les
chercheurs d'autres disciplines c'est
pour moi c'est ça le vrai problème le
débat existe mais il existe que dans un
sens et pas dans l'autre j'en tire lait
symptomatique de ça on parlait tout à
l'heure face gentillesse de parler de
mon petit bouquin mais il ya un
paragraphe je parle déjà l'intégrisme
économique aux liens qui libèrent très
bonne maison d'édition et autres 90 oh
non non c'est beaucoup moins cher mais
le il ya par ailleurs que j'avais
intitulé l'évangile selon saint jean
tirole le livre dont on parlait de jean
tirole qui a vocation à s'adresser à un
public large qui s'appelle économie du
bien commun voilà on s'attend de la part
d'un prix nobel d'économie fin supposée
prix nobel se sait pas un vrai prix
nobel sans revenir dans les détails mais
on sait on attendrait de la part de
quelqu'un aussi hautement distingué en
économie qu il pose des termes de débat
mais non dès le début du bouquin il nous
dit le la base il ya consensus parmi les
économistes pour dire que l'économie
c'est l'individualisme méthodologique
alors c'est quoi ça c'est
l'individualisme mythologie c'est l'idée
qu'ont développé tout à l'heure de dire
l'égoïsme de chacun va conduire au
bien-être pour tous il n'y a pas de
discussions c'est comme ça point et il
ya dans le bouquin ces
multitudes de raisonnements comme ça
l'intervention de l'état avec un plan ça
renvoie à vichy donc le débat est clos
ceux qui sont pour la réduction du temps
de travail mais ils estiment ils ça au
parti d'extrême droite quand tu quand tu
vois les gens comme ça prendre le
contrôle de la dialectique en utilisant
du schopenhauer de bas étage
est-ce qu'il ya quand même des gens pour
se fédérer avec toi pour essayer de dire
la cdu contrôle de dialectique avec
des mécanismes qui sont archiconnus
archi théorisé archi délayé
nom est personne avec toi non bien sûr
que s'il ya des qui est sûr que s'il ya
du mans 81 pellenc ont fait un appel sur
attention attention non mais c'est
toujours la même façon c'est que on a
une vision déformée puisque tu as pas
une division défense mais aussi et
peut-être mais je j'assume ma
subjectivité un économiste et les
subjectif et les plus dangereux sont
ceux qui prétendent aller objectivité
d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai du coup ils
avancent masqués et certainement qu'ils
avancent masqués c'est que la cam qu'ils
ont à vendre et papa de très bonne
qualité mais elle est très belle qui
était plus un cocktail ou qui est de
très bonne qualité pour eux à court
terme effectivement la définition du
goût tout l'est mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que il ya la vision est déformé
parce que
quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas l'économie
et c'est la grande majorité des gens qui
est pas spécialiste d'économie ou de
politique ou de ce que lorsque l'on veut
d'économie politique pour faire simple
et bien
les relais médiatiques on voit toujours
voilà c'est comme on disait tout à
l'heure on voit toujours les mêmes avec
les mêmes discours etc il ya les voilà
servis ont leur rond de serviette et
alors qu'il ya des milliers de personnes
qui pourraient avoir un discours très
intéressant même certainement beaucoup
plus intéressant plus argumentée mais
qui sont effectifs et opératif peut-être
non parce que l'intéressé l'ait les deux
david j'aimerais qu'on parle des flux
migratoires
la cause des flux migratoires c'est quoi
il faut savoir at il des personnes ça
dépend sur les états vont pouvoir
réguler pas régulé il faut les
accueillir tous il faut faire de quoi
alors ça dépend de quel flux migratoires
on parle déjà parce que dans le
livre que j'ai coécrit avec coralie
delaume sur s'appelle la fin de l'union
européenne on a discuté on l'a on s'est
posé la question des flux migratoires
migratoires internes à l'union
européenne et cela déjà sont assez
comment dire sont à ces déstabilisateurs
on a des pays entiers qui se vident de
leur population les piles laissent en
particulier on a des taux de baisse de
la population de migration lévy qui
frôle les 10% donc à venir 10 % la
population une personne sur dix est
parti
c'est que des femmes pour de
prostitution
sahin premièrement ça je pense pas que
ce serait un bien pour ni pour le pays
ni pour eux ni pour la société en
général et 2 c'est en fait surtout des
jeunes et diplômés qui partent et ses
flux migratoires en fait ils sont on
peut pas les réguler parce que par
définition
on est dans un système européen où on
postule la libre installation la libre
circulation des personnes donc ça ces
flux migratoires mois enfin en tout cas
avec coralie scène nous a interpellés
parce que parce qu'on voulait comprendre
l'une des causes de dysfonctionnement de
l'europe et notamment
aujourd'hui on voit que les pays de
l'est ont des commandes hier des votes
pour les pour des parties très populiste
ils sont très axés sur les questions
identitaires d'ailleurs il refuse d eau
fermer les frontières voilà mais parce
que parce que eux ils ont des sociétés
qui sont très violemment attaqué par la
disparition de leurs jeunes actifs
diplômés qui vont partout en europe
surtout attaqué parce qu'il voit des
gens passer à travers travers leur pays
comme cd attend que ça les visages
[Musique]
ouais mais là on vit pas tant que ça
contrairement à l'autriche ou à l'italie
c'est bien celle de wayne
c'est particulier mais eux ils n'ont pas
y'a pas de populisme spécial puisse y
ont même pas dans l'union européenne
mais la pologne par exemple ils ont ils
ont vu aucun étranger arrivé chez eux ou
très peu le problème c'est qu'ils ont
une crispation identitaire qui est liée
à leur perte de ils ont l'impression de
perdre leur rôle alors dire lors leur
dynamisme interne en tant que peuple
parce que justement tous les jeunes
partent et ça on se rend pas compte que
du point de vue des pays qui perdent la
population notamment les jeunes et aider
les plus éduqués c'est un drame absolu
c'est une perte énorme sur place ah non
mais d'abord il ya déjà des livres qu'on
était écrit là-dessus alors je n'ai pas
le titre tu as lu des trucs de gens qui
ont été soulagés regarder les
statistiques aussi de eurostat alors que
concrètement les statistiques d'eurostat
tels sont assez parlantes 1
quand on voit les donc voilà le solde
migratoire dans certains pays qui est
systématiquement négatif en bulgarie en
roumanie dans les pays baltes qui est
très négatif au départ et puis qui
revient un peu positif en dans les pays
plutôt centraux comme république tchèque
hongrie pologne rien que ces
statistiques démontrent qu'il ya un
souci est pareil on a des pays d'accueil
qui sont au départ qui était le pays
d'europe de l'ouest l'espagne l'irlande
essentiellement d'ailleurs et et ensuite
on à la crise
de 2008-2009 qui va faire que ces gens
là vont partir l'espagne qui était un
pays qui a été un cas connu un solde
migratoire très positif qui venaient
d'europe qui venait aussi des pays
d'amérique latine dont elle a eu à la
une solde migratoire de plus de 10% de
sa population donc énorme et bien c'est
pas étonnant que c'est à ce moment là
qui est lui la crise de l'immobilier et
une bulle immobilière qui s'est créée
parce qu'il fallait bien logés
construire tout des logements pour ça
dès que la crise et de se terminer des
gens vont partir de la bulle immobilière
de l'espagne rappelle moi un petit peu
agacé les années 2000 c'est le moment où
l'espagne accueille des millions de
personnes qu'il faut loger et entraîner
les normands n ya pas que ça y'a pas que
ça a bien sûr que ça il ya eu cet effet
là mais essentiellement si une christine
c'est une bulle immobilière partout 1-1
à madrid donc dans toutes les grandes
villes pareil en irlande donc le
l'accueil de l'accueil de très nombreux
migrants est aussi un problème pour les
pays d'accueil pas forcément sur des
questions identitaires n'y a pas eu de
hausse du parti populiste en espagne en
irlande mais il ya eu une bulle
immobilière dans ces deux pays aient
regardé regarde aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe en allemagne un million de
personnes accueillies pour la seule
année 2015 on n'a jamais vu ça en europe
alors si elles sont effectivement des
des syriens des réfugiés de tous pays se
sont aussi des européens parce qu'on a
sous qualifiés pour 1,99 alors pour ceux
qui viennent alors ça dépend c'est très
compliqué par exemple il ya eu quand on
regarde qui arrivent là aussi je fais
référence aux celle-ci d'eurostat parce
qu'il ya des celtic détaillées sur qui
arrive en allemagne avant 2015 c'est
essentiellement des européens et des
jeunes de moins de 40 ans et on a depuis
2015 2016 on a là aussi une hausse très
fort des prix immobiliers en allemagne
alors que l'allemagne avait eu aucune
aucune croissance de ses prêts
immobiliers pas de bulle immobilière et
sept-îles l'un des avantages de
l'allemagne c'est que le prix de
logements est très accessible depuis
l'entrée massive
de fait l'arrivée massive de migrants
qu'ils soient européens ou extra
européens et bien là on commence à voir
une crise immobilière donc c'est des
choses qui sont quand même très
déstabilisant aussi au niveau économique
et bien sûr et bien on a aussi des
partis populistes qui arrive en
allemagne s'améliorer ça va s'améliorer
comment ça se passait ce que les
facteurs de crise économique crise
climatique
les facteurs de guerre de
déstabilisation pays pour aller chercher
des métaux rares de l'or de l'argent des
bananes à ce qu'on veut c'est sûr que
l'esc à la question est ce que la
question qu'on se pose c'est est ce
qu'on construit un mur ou pas et où est
ce qu'on va le construire je vois pas un
mur en milliers de la méditerranéen
personnellement s'appelle des mines
maritime
le problème c'est que concrètement
- est-ce que ça va s'améliorer c'est
impossible à dire en tout cas pas dans
le court terme bien sûr que quand on
quand on ravage la syrie et grandissent
à se dégrader ou conscience pas
forcément parce que il faut espérer que
après je ne sais pas mais concrètement
là la guerre en syrie a quand même amené
énormément de personnes erdogan qui
stocke et mal à personne de leurs
affaires pour le compte de l'europe
parce que c'est un peu sa façon de
tranquille contre son prochain coup
d'état
est sûr c'est que ce qui est sûr c'est
que il a une pouvoir de rétorsion
l'important est que l'on va rejoindre
ont dit non mais on apprend on à
bombarder
la libye au nom de la démocratie
gsa entraîner une désorganisation totale
parce qu'on avait des accords avec
halimi qui étaient du même genre que
ceux qu'on croit que l'allemagne a pour
toile la signature des accords
méditerranéen vers 2008 par sarkozy ou
baky et à grande pompe nice est ce que
c'était au départ les prémices d'une
garde prétorienne européenne contre les
flux migratoires
je pense qu'il y avait alors c'est
difficile à dire et surtout à juger de
ce que de sarkozy avait en tête mais
clairement avant les printemps arabes en
gros on avait qu'un en partie déléguer
la gestion des flux migratoires au pays
du maghreb sont essentiellement libye
egypte ces pays là en gros il y avait
l'idée et je pense qu'il y avait dans
l'idée de sarkozy de créer le
l'euroméditerranée cette association il
y avait cette idée là évidemment ces
régimes corrompus d'ailleurs jusqu'à la
moelle se sont effondrés pour elle à lui
tout seul
j'étais un peu stimulant eu
moi moi je ne peux pas dire ce que
concrètement je veux pas rentrer dans ce
truc là j'ai pas des connaissances
spécifiques là dessus mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que de fait ils sont effondrés
de fait en libye on a bombardé ça aussi
c'est clair et celle du rugby toi nous
boude souvent touchants non mais je
écoute tu me dis parfois que je
n'exagère pas coudre on exagère les
connaissances quand je les ai pas je
préfère dire que je ne sais pas quoi
vas-y continent je dis simplement que
clairement
ce qui s'est passé en libye et les
bombardements et la situation
catastrophique qui a en libye alors bien
sûr je n'y suis pas allé m'enfin c'est
assez facile à voir
ça ça implique clairement ça veut dire
que les réfugiés sont fall et les
personnes sont le régulation des
migrations qui était fait par les
libyens elle est plus faite et même au
contraire on a des mafias qui organise
l'immigration mais mais au fond le vrai
problème il est que dans les pays le
départ les situations sont
catastrophiques voilà tant que la syrie
se relève pas il y aura toujours des
syriens qui partiront ou qui seront dans
des camps aux alentours le soudan du sud
c'est des systèmes ou l'erythrée cdc des
régimes qui sont morts par pat pas
partout il ya des gars des pays
africains qui vont bien tout où le to a
pas mal forcément mais met clairement on
a des pays qui sont qui vont mal mais la
question de savoir est ce que ça va
perdurer dans le temps moi je crois que
l'afrique à une transition démographique
qui a amorcé donc il y aura sans doute
d'une biographie qui va être qui va se
réduire par rapport à ce qu'on a connu
aujourd'hui même si ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps on a une croissance
économique et ford en bout nombreux pays
qui vont attirer des migrants par
exemple la côte d'ivoire de l'indre à
langolen à l'angola je suis pas sûr mais
je ne sais pas je connais plutôt
l'afrique de l'ouest
le sénégal fin j'avais regardes tu
connais pas je connais je connais les
statistiques quoi un voilà je vois que
les les ces pays sont des pays qui
connaissent une croissance connaît je
connais aussi les étudiants qui est de
ces pays qui sont de mieux en mieux
éduqués et donc je vois que d'ailleurs
les gens qui arrivent aujourd'hui en
france et pas des sénégalais au long
saint-david ton pour un billet d'avion
d'eric je le dois aussi aux billets
d'avion non et sur quoi alors j'ai la
démographie et surtout les flux
migratoires
il ya une double kenya les raisons
démographiques il ya trois raisons
principales les raisons pendant de la
migration il ya trois raisons
principales
il ya des raisons de guerre il ya le
changement climatique limiter les
migrants climatiques vont être les par
centaines de millions après ce qui est
prévu et il ya de la migration
économique alors sur le champ
sur les 3 où normalement on ya moyen de
d'avoir d'avoir une action si on si on
souhaite bon on s'étonne aujourd'hui
qu'un grand nombre de personnes de pays
pauvres souhaitent venir dans le supposé
eldorado européen
dont on leur balance les images à
longueur de temps que c'est merveilleux
et que qu'on est les meilleurs et que
l'on fait tout mieux que les autres et
après on s'étonne qu'ils veulent venir
bon parce que d'un autre côté si
comment dire nos nos économies aussi dit
développés elles se sont développées
grâce à de la main d'oeuvre de moniteurs
et là des super prédateur on connaît les
questions de ressources naturelles
notre développement il se fait aussi en
pillant un certain nombre de ressources
naturelles que ce soit en afrique en
amérique latine ces terres à face à ses
vieux comme la colonisation est donc
bien évidemment quand on a pas d'espoir
dans son pays
on essaie d'aller voir ailleurs si
l'herbe est plus verte vous êtes comment
on les arrête comment moi je pense déjà
qu'il faudrait une bonne fois pour
toutes considéré que me grey c'est pas
un choix c'est pas partir en vacances au
club med c'est un déchirement parce que
l'on est c'est vrai on sépare de sa
famille de son environnement de son de
ses amis pour aller dans quelque chose
qu'on espère meilleur mais dont on
s'aperçoit assez souvent qu'il ne l'ait
pas incorrect toi aussi je veux le droit
regret si je vais me gave au canada
bascule en france il ya plus qu'une
bande de cons gouverné par des branches
des bras cassés je vais je vais être
mieux au canada je suis méfiant des
nouveaux copains gens sont sympas le
climat extrême et là on parle pas on
parle pas de la même migration moi je
parle de la migration voilà en
provenance des pays pauvres notamment la
migration africaine monsieur inquiet du
dieu et je comprends bien ce qu'il ya
migration aimé mais je comprends bien
l'âge de la ce dont je parle c'est ça
c'est pas moi aussi je pourrais trouver
un bel emploi
d'ailleurs voilà canadien qui viennent
chez nous j'ai jamais entendu dire que
ça pose des problèmes ou les français
qui vont au canada je crois pas non plus
et maintenant fait parce que le canada
est un pays d'émigration aussi une fan
d'immigration plutôt ce que nous ce que
nous on est pas on n'est pas vraiment
est de moins en moins donc on a une
responsabilité alors je reviens sur la
migration c'est un déchirement c'est pas
un choix comme ça c'est souvent une
contrainte parce que voilà que ce soit
économique
au type de guerre rappelons nous que
entre 39 et 45 l'immigrant c'était les
européens et j'allais accueilli la
ceinture médicale en blindant dans plein
de pays dont on ne veut plus des
spécialisés dans les nouveaux modèles de
développement est ce que dans tes
modèles de développement inclut le
prisme de lecture là qu'est ce que tu
proposes tu es solution mais moi mon
prisme de lecture de toute manière en
économie c'est dire que moi je fais pas
de la science économique fait de
l'économie politique et que donc par
définition un problème économique est
d'abord un problème politique et au
moins au moins autant un problème
politique donc moi j'essaie de regarder
l'économie sous l'angle de rapport de
force et comment créer des rapports de
force pour faire évoluer les choses
alors c'est pas simple ça marche pas
bien ça marche pas bien mais regarde les
révolutions arabes est ce que quelqu'un
aurait imaginé que ben ali qui avait un
régime de fer en tunisie depuis 25 ans
allait partir comme ça comme un
misérable en 15 jours parce que
rappelons nous que le déclenchement de
la révolution tunisienne c'est un
vendeur de rue qui s'était fait piquer
sa marchandise par la police
tunisienne et qui disent felli flash un
beau nom mais en face à ces partis de
chez fauchon dernier certains qu'ils ont
anticipé d'ailleurs philippe caduque
année nous des gens qui non mais à
presque y avait eu d'erreur était sur le
terrain mais qui avec il y avait le
terreau etc mais je veux dire le voilà
souvent c'est un élément peut-être enfin
important ou anecdotique je dis pas que
c'est pas que c'est anecdotique un type
se se tuent parce que on l'a persécutés
mais
voilà donc on sait pas on sait pas et on
a l'impression c'est justement ça qui
permet d'avoir un peu d'optimisme c'est
qu'on a l'impression qu'on est face à
des ré des trucs qui peuvent pas changer
les soviétiques y six mois avant il
savait pas que ça allait s'effondrer non
plus à ma fin des années 80 ans
peut-être mais enfin
tant que c'est pas arrivé
on a du mal à y croire
et pour nous ça va peut-être être ce qui
va nous arriver dans quelques temps
mireille
avant tu commences je vais prévenir des
deux acolytes
préparer la dernière question qui est
laissé un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
mireille tu termineras sur cette
question
tout de suite l'occasion d'envoyer une
photo non je vois juste complété par
rapport aux migrations infections à
l'émigration
pour les questions écologiques elles
vont devenir de plus en plus important
il faut se rappeler que quand même là
que le réchauffement climatique provient
en très très grande majorité du mode de
fonctionnement et de niveau de vie des
pays des pays occidentaux c'est à dire
que la dette climatique aller de l'autre
côté donc moi je trouve assez
insupportable ou carrément de dire ah
ils faut qu'ils restent chez eux qu'ils
se débrouillent chez eux et c'est alors
même que c'est nous mêmes qui les ont
mis dans les conditions c'est pas
simplement par la colle par les
questions de colonisation de prédation
et donc effectivement du fait que
politiquement en un terrain dans ces
pays pour retrouver des ressources et
pour extraire des ressources mais aussi
au niveau climatique à dire que voilà on
a mis quand même la planète dans un
sacré état et il ya des populations
entières qui sont menacés par ce
relâchement climatique et on est
maintenant vous restez chez vous ça nous
concerne pas donc le capitalisme est
délétère pour la le climat
ça je pense que c'est à dire le
contraire ça serait compliqué de
démontrer que ce sont pas le cas donc
les mouvements écologiques écologistes
c'est compliqué de combattre le
capitalisme c'est ça c'est compliqué
mais oui il faut un sarrau ça rejoint
les la question que vous avez posé tout
le temps c'est à dire que évidemment la
question la question c'est la question
du rapport de force on a bien du
changement de paradigme et du changement
de paradigme et du changement de sens il
ya vraiment une intrication social
écologie politique kiki l'intrication
inextricable non j'espère pas j'espère
pas david un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
c'est à dire moi je pense que l'économie
n'est pas si difficile en a parlé on
finalement on a en a pas moi je on a
beaucoup parlé d'économie d'économie
politique on a pas fait d grande
équation n'a pas fait de deux choses
très comment dire très très
inaccessibles pour quelqu'un d'un peu
intelligents et conscients et je pense
que la première chose qu'il faut faire
c'est reprendre la main sur le politique
sur l'économie est considéré que
l'économie n'est pas une science qui
s'impose au genre et vous et bien déjà
on étudie la question on essaie de 2,2
de s'apercevoir qu'on peut agir et que
les lois de l'offre et la demande c'est
pas automatique c'est que on peut pas
dire parce que le marché a décidé que
lui devait être payé 500 euros et lui 1
500 millions que c'est une norme et
c'est comme ça que doit se faire en gros
pour moi le le conseil que j'ai envie de
donner aux gens c'est ne vous laissez
pas avoir ne pensez pas que parce qu'un
économiste l'a dit ou parce qu'un modèle
le montre et bien voilà c'est ça la
réalité et la vérité le la capacité
qu'ont à d'agir et par le vote par
l'implication citoyenne par aussi la
lecture et l'approfondissement des
questions et bien on peut se dire que
l'on peut agir sur les marchés et pas
laisser les marchés décider de nos
propres vies rick pourrait s'avérer un
peu dans le même sens c'est à dire il
faut qu'il y ait un petit cours
d'autodéfense intellectuelle c'est ça
oui ben oui il faut cultiver
le doute le doute c'est je crois que
c'était bertrand russell qui disait que
les gens qui doutent enfin les gens qui
savent sont ceux qui doutent et les gens
qui savent pas sont ceux qui ont le plus
de certitudes
je sais quelque chose comme ça je sais
plus si j'ai la phrase exacte mais
c'était ça voulait dire ça si vous
cherchez des cons chercher ceux qui ont
des certitudes voilà ça ça revient ça
non mais de douter et voilà d'être
curieux et de pas considérer a priori
que c'est pas pour nous que ça on peut
pas comprendre que ça on peut pas en
traités etc et de réinvestir le champ du
politique mais de politique au sens
noble politique c'est quoi c'est le
débat d'idées c'est la confrontation d
idées d une société où la science même
progresse toujours à partir de
confrontation de grands débats
théoriques
philosophique etc sur le sens où on veut
aller collectivement et comment on y va
alors on n'a pas de solution clé en main
moi je suis toujours
il faut créer un rapport de force bon et
ce rapport de force il ne peut être créé
qu'à partir du moment où on est
conscient qu'il y en a un et qu'il y en
a un et que on veut le changer à partir
de demain en ce moment d'être curieux
oui c'est du quai alors s'éduquer ça
passe pas forcément par l'école ou
l'université mais lire
réfléchir questionné ne pas tout
accepter pour argent comptant bon c'est
vrai c'est assez banal tout cela mais
mais c'est un peu la base tout à l'heure
on parlait du fait que les gens ne vont
plus voter mais moi je suis intimement
persuadé on a les parties les grands
partis toujours qui versent des larmes
de crocodile à chaque fin d'année à
chaque scrutin disant oh la la il ya
trop d'abstention mais intérieurement
ils s'en foutent je suis sûr ils sont
même plutôt content puisque ceux qui
vont pas voter votre et jamais pour eux
donc au contraire il est donc si on veut
changer les choses il faut justement ce
essayer de
ramener ce qui je ne sais pas on baisse
les bras sans qu'il ya ait rien
possibilité de faire s'il ya toujours
possibilité dire hey du mot de la fin
est le conseil pour les jeunes c'est
souvent moi je dirais aux jeunes de
faire confiance à l'encontre
subjectivité alors propre expérience que
je crois que justement tout ce qu'on a
dit quand même est traversé par l'idée
qu' il ya quelque chose de leur sol de
techniques d'extérieur les experts etc
je pense qu'une des manières de résister
c'est vraiment de construire sa
subjectivité alors après ça suffit pas
effectivement
il ya au niveau politique il ya deux
choses à mon avis fondamental au delà
des questions peu économique et des
propositions économiques on a dans les
économistes atterrés c'est effectivement
remettre au centre les questions de
démocratie et réfléchir sur la question
des limites c'est à dire que je crois
pas qu'on puisse continuer à réfléchir
les alternatives sont posés la question
de la limite est la démocratie pour
reprendre quelqu'un que j'apprécie
beaucoup qui s'appelle castoriadis qui
dit que finalement la démocratie c'est
un régime d'auto limitation à dire que
quand on est vraiment dans un système
démocratique
on pose la question de comment nous
mêmes on s'auto limite presse que ça
s'arrête c'est pas ça veut pas dire que
tout doit être petit où tout doit être
entouré de moyens je ne sais pas mais
par contre on sait qu'à un moment donné
une nation une commune une entreprise
pose collectivement la question de sa
propre limite et ça je pense que c'est
pas assez discuté je pense que c'est ça
c'est ça mon avis ce sont des pensées
qui sont plutôt du coup du côté de la
radicalité saignerons de la bifurcation
par rapport au capitalisme je sais ça
que je veux dire aux jeunes faire
confiance à la propre expérience arrêtez
de penser que ça passe par les écrans
par les choses qui sont hors sol donc ça
veut dire un propre subjectivité et
poser la question de la démocratie et
des limites je vais à merci merci merci
[Musique]
e